Chad GPT a game changer in artificial
intelligence developed using open AI
Advanced GPT 3.5 architecture Chad GPT
is designed to engage educate and
entertain with the V pool of knowledge
and the ability to tailor responses to
individual preferences chat GPT is here
to offer valuable insights respond to
questions and initiate engaging
conversations whether you want to
explore a wide range of topics or seek
assistance with creative projects Chad
GPT is ready to embark on a journey of
Discovery with you whether you are a
marketing expert a cyber security
specialist a developer or a blogger chat
GPT is your ideal companion chat GP
currently has more than 100 million
users and this eii technology is gaining
huge Fame with the time on that note if
you are looking to become an AI expert
then have a look at wide range of eiml
courses by simply learn in collaboration
with top universities across the globe
by enrolling in any of these
certification programs you will gain
expertise in the skills like generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPT
explainable AI machine learning
algorithms supervised and unsupervised
learning model training and optimization
and there is much more on the list with
hands-on experience in the tools like
chat GPT di python open CV t flow you
will catch the eye of top recruiters so
what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now an year of experien is
preferred to enroll in these courses
find the course Link in the description
box so before we move ahead in this
video consider subscribing to Simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from us so without any
further Ado let's start by knowing top
AI tools in the industry followed by
detailed explanation of chart GPD over
to our tutoral
ever get stuck while writing an email
finding the right words or stuck on that
article you can't find the final words
for well to get rid of this writer's
blog a myid of AI tools help you achieve
your targets we are now at a time when
artificial intelligence stands to do
many jobs better and more efficiently
due to the lack of human error it's not
just content creation AI can fine use in
a ton of scenarios let us go through
some of the best AI tools available
today that can boost your productivity
at number 10 you have magic eraser by
Magic Studio the Magic Eraser removes
unwanted images from your pictures using
artificial intelligence it can decipher
the backgrounds and remove unnecessary
elements out of a picture beat unwanted
Birds on a landscape shs or branding on
social media post select the element to
be removed using the Eraser and let the
Tool Work its magic next at number nine
we have the thing translator this tool
allows users to point their camera at an
object and hear the translation in a
different language using the cloud
Vision API and the translate API of
Google the translator serves as a
godsent for foreign Travelers or just
people trying to learn a new language
with both the Google API set to develop
even more over time expect the thing
translator to become more helpful than
ever at number eight we have tab 9 tab 9
analyzes and recommends your next blocks
of code based on the context and syntax
get lengthy accurate and creative code
completions to become a more efficient
developer tab night's AI completions may
be executed on a developer's laptop
behind a firewall or even on the cloud
it recommends code completions based on
your coding Tendencies it supports the
most common languages such as JavaScript
Python and typescript and even more
Niche languages such as rust go and Bash
irrespective of what your text tack
looks like tab n will boost your speed
at number seven we have Trevor AI Trevor
AI is a daily planning program that
leverages intelligent time blocking to
connect your list of activities and
calendar it supports integration and
two-way sync with services like Google
Calendar and todoist taking control of
how you spend your time based on
schedules and time frames it helps plan
your habits and work life to create a
streamlined approach to your day using
artificial intelligence this helps you
focus on the individual task rather than
worrying about cramming your busy
schedule into the entire day at number
six we have deep Nostalgia deep
Nostalgia is an online tool developed by
a company called my Heritage and can
animate faces from old pictures my
Heritage licensed this unique technology
for animating photographs from did which
is a firm specializing in video
reconstruction using deep learning my
Heritage use this technology to animate
the faces in Old images and generate
high quality lifelike video footage the
tool works equally well for black and
white pictures and photographs taken in
color so needless to say the results are
pretty astonishing and can be quite
moving in many cases number five on our
list goes to durable durable helps
create sample websites in under 30
seconds for people starting a new
business or who are generally not well
versed in web development just choose
the type of business you are running and
the name of your company to get sample
designs made immediately from spaces
assigned to customer reviews to buttons
allotted for social media profiles
durables ensures the websites match the
latest trends in web development you can
restyle the colors and headings or sign
up to further customize the website
based on your requirements at number
four we have Jasper with the growth of
AI everything it's only a matter of time
until AI is utilized to produce content
for your blog social networks websites
and other platforms Jasper AI formerly
known as Javis is a lowcost service that
generates original material such as blog
entries for you it's simple enough for
almost anyone to use all you have to do
is enter general information about what
you want to address and the AI will will
do the rest providing over 50 templates
Jasper can handle a significant amount
of the heavy lifting for topics that are
often written about the AI can provide a
solid foundation of information to which
you can subsequently add your own unique
Insight number three on our list goes to
Tetra with Tetra you don't have to note
down your minutes of meeting every day
Tetra dials into your calls and
essentially takes notes for you allowing
you to focus on the discussion now and
remember all of it later authentic
speech recognition has yet to reach the
level where it can find function as a
viable alternative zra also has a notes
viewer with each audio bite synced with
the notes this level of detail allows
you to focus on the meetings discussion
without making individual notes
throughout the call at number two we
have the dolly 2 the latest
groundbreaking text to picture generator
from open aai is called Dolly do it
enables users to produce visuals in
response to text cues users can use this
generator to transform the imaginative
thoughts into life like Graphics if you
scroll through Twitter and look for the
# dolly2 you will be greeted with many
images and artworks shared by many
people based on different topics from
Victorian era style pictures of aliens
to just plain portrait style images
dolly2 has all its bases covered
regarding variety the AI is taught via
deep learning how to make text to image
associations which the model later uses
to recreate the relevant images finally
we have chat GPT at number one open has
unveiled chat GPT a powerful new chat Bo
that uses an improved version of its AI
technology to Converse in plain English
English while gbt has existed for a
while this model has reached a critical
point it is beneficial for a broad range
of activities from developing software
to generating company ideas to composing
a wedding toast while prior iterations
of the program could potentially execute
this tasks the output quality was far
worse than that of a typical person
since its debut Twitter has been
bombarded with people using it for
unusual and bizarre purposes such as
creating weight loss strategies and
gin's novels and providing instructions
on retrieving a peanut butter sandwich
from a VCR it seems chat GPT will serve
as an important Monument for artificial
intelligence to be welcomed in the
consumer sphere so that wraps up our
video on the top 10 eii tools for
2023 whether you're a tech Enthusiast a
expert or just curious about the new and
exciting development you won't want to
miss this discussion about the latest
air sensation I'm talking about Chad gbt
a highly Advanced language model based
on gpt3 technology developed by open AI
Chad GPT is a state of art language
generation AI model that has captured
the attention of millions of people
around the world it has been trained on
a massive data set of text Data making
it one of the most largest language
models to date but do you know a new
version of GPD is coming up it's called
GPD 4 and it will support up to 1
trillion parameters compared to 175
billion parameters of gpt3 now you might
be wondering what are these parameters
so what it means when a user sends a
query to the New Year version of chat
gbt then it will process that query with
all one fing parameters to deliver a
correct and suitable response isn't it
mind-blowing not only that gp4 will have
more applications than its predecessor
gpt3 the gpt3 has various applications
like text generation text summarization
automated content generation application
and is also being used by various
companies like viable feable studio and
algolia aside from it its remarkable
language handling ability GPD 4 has the
possibility of being utilized for
additional functions such as generating
images and videos this is due to the
fact gbd4 is constructed using the
Transformer architecture which has
demonstrated Effectiveness in multiple
machine learning assignments including
computer vision psychologist and
cognitive scientist Gary marker said
that he can guarantee that gb4 will blow
the minds He also mentioned that gp4
will totally Eclipse Chad GPT as it has
more parameters and is being trained
with more data however the CEO Sam Alman
debunks false information surrounding
the company's upcoming chat gbt 4 Alman
said that he did not have an actual AGI
that is an artificial general
intelligence that could drial humans in
learning in existence the release of
Chad GPT and other AI powered Chad
boards had had a major impact on Google
search business with the New York Times
reporting that it prompted Google's
management to declare State emergency
referred to as Cod red GPD 4 with its
improved complexity and quicker response
time has the potential to enhance
communication by making it more natural
and accurate for instance short sentence
responses from a chatboard can reduce
the likelihood of people clicking on ads
this AI technology could bring about a
major transformation in the economy
Google employees have been assigned the
task of developing AI products with gp4
that can match the capability of gpt3
such as its capability of generating art
music and other visuals that open a is
currently capable of Microsoft has
invested $3 billion into the open Ai and
is reportedly in discussion to invest an
additional 10 billion as reported by the
New York Times the paper also stated
that the release of gp4 is expected to
take place in the first quarter of 2023
Matt mlan a venture capitalist with
knowledge of gbd4 hinted that the new
system May possesses multimodal
capabilities which refers to the
capability of functioning in various
modes such as text images and sounds the
gp4 chatboard built using Microsoft
extensive data center network has the
potential to be similar to chat GPD
generating only text or it could be
incorporate both text and images however
Sam Alman has cautioned not to set
expectations too high so at this point
it is difficult to say with certainty
what gp4 will look like and what it will
be capable of so what do you think about
Chad gb4 do let us know in the comment
section below and moving on now we'll
start with a chat jbt to automate our
Excel and we have some Excel files I
will upload them in the link with the
GitHub so you can freely download them
and you can also try this project with
those files and here we are with the
chat JP so now we are on the chat jpt
website and here you can see that
there's a try chat jpd option and when
we click it we will be redirecting to
the chat jpt the chat box and before
that I will show you the
homepage it's showing us the samples
what we can do with the jat
GB the
methods and there's the collect
demonstration data and train a
supervised policy like how it's trained
how open a has trained the chat gbt and
its
limitations they have mentioned all the
things here iterative deployment
and moving on now we will log in to our
chat
jpd I will log in with my Google
account tell us about you and this is my
name and he's
asking my phone
number so I will get this blurred so you
guys won't be seeing my phone number
okay he's asking for the code I'm
waiting for the code after entering the
OTP you would be directed to this page
that is chat GPT and this is the Field
Box where you can write any query in the
simple natural language that would be
English and the chat jpt would answer
your
questions and if we talk about chat JP
uh little bit information about chj that
it's an AI powered chatboard that has
been developed by open Ai and the
chatboard understands natural language
and responds in a humanlike manner it is
based on GPT 3.5
which is a language model and the
chatboard was unveiled as a prototype on
November 30 2022 while announcing the
chatboard open a wrote on its
announcement page that we have trained a
model called chat jpt which interacts in
a conversational way the dialogue format
makes it possible for chat jpd to answer
followup questions admit its mistake
challenge incorrect premises and reject
inappropriate requests so now we will
talk about the chat jib so chat jbt is
an AI powered chat board that has been
developed by the artificial intelligence
and it's been researched by the company
open Ai and the chatboard understands
natural language and responds in a
human-like manner it is based on GP 3.5
which is a language model the chatbot
was unveiled as a prototype on November
30 2022 while announcing the chatboard
openi wrote on its announcement page
that we have trained a model called chat
jpd which interacts in a conversational
way the dialogue format makes it
possible for chat jpd to answer followup
questions admit its mistake challenge
incorrect premises and reject
inappropriate
requests so this is
JJ and it's been boing all the
developers around the globe so now we'll
start with automating Excel with the
help of chat jpt and with the help of
Python
language so first
first we will create a folder and see
the Excel files with which we will use
Python and with the help of chat
jpt we will automate
them so first we'll create a folder for
our project and we'll create in Python
projects and name it
as automate Excel
using chat
jpt and inside this we will open the
command
prompt and now we will open any ideally
so that we'll write a request to chat
GPT and he'll answer us with the
suitable code and that code we will copy
paste into our idle and run it if it
gives any error we will copy past the
error same to the chat jpt and as I know
he answers them so here we will open our
ideally and for that we are writing a
command that is code space period and
that will open our ideally that is
Visual Studio
word now we have open our ID and first
we'll create a file
here or first we'll see our Excel files
on which we will do the
Automation and for that we'll get back
to our
folder and here we have the number
folder in which we have two files that
is CSV files phone number and phone
number two
and other we have the sales folder and
in that we have the data of the sales of
the Year
2022 so we'll use these files sales and
the number so we'll cut them
and get to a
folder and inside the number file no uh
we'll start with
sales first we'll do the automation with
the sales
files so we'll open the sales folder and
inside that we will create a file that
would be the py
file and the first automation we would
be doing is concatenating all the files
in a single Excel file we have the files
from January to December that is the
sales files so we'll concatenate them
and ask the chat GPT to write the code
to con sorry to concatenate all
these so for
that we name the files conate
only
inate _ data
P so now we'll give the command to the
chat
jpt so here is a chat jpd and here we
will write a command for it that would
be I have 12 Excel
files and I want to concatenate
them and we'll also mention the name
named
January spelling January is this only
but we'll check with the file
jary and then we have February
and moving
on so on we have till
December so we have all these 12 files
and now we'll command him to use
Python to concatenate the data inside
the 12 Exel files into one
file
so this is our Command and it's in the
simplest natural language that is the
English language so we'll just press
enter okay it shows us that an error
occurred if
the so for this thing we'll just copy
the open a link and paste it here and
open it as the chat jpt is seeing a huge
traffic sometimes it
shows these
errors so he's verifying us whether we
are a robot or not so we will agree with
the chat
jbt and answer it questions
here
it's asking again okay now we are clear
with the chat jity and we'll paste our
Command here and press
enter and here you can see that it has
started answering our question that you
can use the pandas library in Python to
read in the data from each of the Excel
files and use the concat function to
combine the data from all the FES into
data frame is an example of how you want
use
okay is going in a very right
Manner and he has imported pandas and
then created a data and using the for
[Music]
Loop he is going through all the months
reading the Excel file and appending
okay
done and result he has concatenated but
he has not created
the Excel file where we can see all the
data and he has also not printed it so
what we want so first we'll
see what does this code do as I have
seen so it will concatenate but it has
not created the Excel file in which we
can see all the data so we have copied
the code we will paste it
here save it and run
it
and most important thing you have to
import the Panda's library and if you
have not installed it please install it
in the command prompt with the command
pip install pandas or you can use it in
the
terminal
okay it has not found the january.
XLS okay so JN UA are
by
spelling we'll
see what error it
expects we'll save this and run once
again so we'll just copy the error and
write it back to chat jpt and see
how does it
respond okay is seeing is indicating
that the Pand library is unable to find
the Excel file you trying to read in
based on the error message look like the
files are not located in the same
directory as the python
script okay we'll see that but we have
the python script and the
library and in the
same
folder
yeah concatenate to py and we'll check
once again
here data py
yeah they are in the same folder and why
we have this
error Okay so
so the is we have opened our
IDE
in automated Excel using Chad jpd folder
and currently we are in sales
folder so it is not
recognizing the
directory so what we'll
do we'll copy all these
files copy the sales
files and paste it
here
now now we'll run the port that chat jpt
provided
us okay uh yeah it has run
successfully exed successfully okay
we'll try once again we kill the
terminal save it and run it
again now we'll see yeah it has executed
successfully uh but the thing is it has
not converted it
into a single Excel file for that we'll
write you forgot
to
create the
concatenated file as we also haven't
mentioned in our
Command
specifically so we have to be specific
with the commands
Also let's
see yeah after concerting the data frame
to export to a Excel file we can just
write this
command and index equal to false here
okay and he is giving all the
explanations so you can just read them
correct I apologize for the site to
create a new Excel file that contains
the con data you can use the 2core Excel
method of the data frame here is an
example of how you could do this okay
you create a new Excel file named
concore data. xlsx in the same directory
as your python script and it will
contain the concatenated data form from
all of the original Excel file you could
also use the 2core Cs meth method to
save the data frame in CSV format yeah
we can do that
also okay
we make the xlsx
file and just beneath
it
yeah C part
two okay we don't need any path we'll
just do it here
only here result.
2XL data
xlsx so we'll save this and run
it
it is showing that it has executed
successfully and yeah outside the sales
folder will close it you can see that it
has created the concore data
xlsx so for that we move here yeah it
has created it
here we'll open
it and first I will show you what these
files
contain so every file have the entry of
around th000 every file has
1,000
entries so the conate file should have
around
12,000 so this is the concore data and
if we go
beneath yeah we can
see
2000 and it's yeah it says it has con
canulated all the data so yeah chat GPT
responded and we have to precise with
the commands what we are writing in
English as it has not mentioned to
convert it into Excel file now when we
have WR it again it has done that now
moving on we will do the second
Automation and for that we'll move back
to our ideally and the next automation
we will be doing would be that we will
be using the sum and the average
function to all the files that is from
January to December files and
we'll use sum and average function I
I'll show you where we will
use so it's going
data so we'll open the August
file and here you can see the quantity
in the edge
column so we'll average down the
quantity so what is the average per
customer
and in the J column we have the total
cost so we'll add all the cost in all
the files this is the August file from
January to December we will do in column
H the average for the quantities and
column J we'll do the sum of the total
amount per customer and we'll get it
printed at the last column that would be
we have the th000
entries it's going to
h11 so we would get it printed on
h102 and the sum we would get it printed
on
J12 okay so moving on we'll close this
files we will get back to a chat jpd and
give him a command that I have 12 Excel
files and we'll tell him that
we have named
them
January then we
have
February
then we have till
December and now we want you to use
Python
to
apply the sum
formula the sum formula and the average
formula so the sum formula would be
applied from J2 to
j101 we see okay we have closed file
yeah what I remember some formula
from J2 2 J 1 0 1 okay
and the average
function and now we want him to use the
average
formula from H2 to
h11 okay and that would be in all the
Excel
files and we want him to write the
results in the cells and that would be
J12 and
h12
respectively so we have to be precise
with the commands and we have an error
here uh that is done and yeah it's all
done I'll just give this command to chat
jpt and see how it answers use the pan
library in Python to read okay and
perform the sum and average calculations
good and then write the results back to
the same file here is an example of how
you could do this yeah we writing in the
same
file okay we are importing par PD and
running a loop for all the months we
have read all the Excel files one by one
and we are taking the
cell one and I location and doing the
sum and doing the mean of the edge
column yeah it's
good
Excel yeah I think it would do our
job so we'll copy this and create a new
file and name it
as some.
py and inside this we will paste the
code that our GPT has provided
us and we'll run this and it has
executed successfully okay no uh we got
an error that
is okay okay okay it has made the
mistake
okay go
it okay we just see what
query We R I have 12 ex files name Jan
to the Su and use Python to apply the Su
formula from J2 to
j11 and the average formula from H2 to
h101 in all the files and write the
results
okay
done uh we would be a little
specific this Cs
j102 and
okay okay okay okay yeah we once again
submit it if we did didn't
get okay yeah now he has used the
open yxl Library that's
good yeah that would be working for
us let's
see what he will provide to
us
yeah she active
and
okay
okay yeah
think uh it can serve the purpose but
first we'll run it so he is giving us
the explanation for what he has written
this code that is this code will apply
the sum formula to the range j22 j101
and the average formula to the range H2
to h101 in all the Excel files that is a
results will be written in
j102 and h12 respectively it is
important to note that this code will
overwrite the original file so that it's
recommended to make a backup okay we
don't need that and we have backup in
the sales folder also so you can also
the read uncore XEL andore XEL function
from
P
okay so we'll try this
code
uh it is not return to import OS and
guys uh you have to install all these
libraries open pyxl I have already
installed them you can search on the
browser that open pyxl installation
Python and it would be directed to pypi
tocom that's the official website for
the particular libraries and there you
can see the command that would be the
PIP install and the particular command
for the module name
uh it is showing that it has run
successfully so we'll just see if it has
done its job or
not and in the AIL file we have in the
HED column that is the average of the
HED column that P the items and in the J
column we have the total sum of the
amount of the customers yeah
the query has run successfully Chad jpt
has provided us with the perfect code
heads off to the jat jbt and moving on
now we'll do some other
automations and
now what we can
do uh we have other files that is phone
number and phone number
two and what it
contains
it contains the phone
numbers so what we could do is we could
add the plus 91 extension that is the
country code for India we will ask chat
jpt to add the country code plus 91 to
both the
files so I'll close these
files and
first we'll copy them and paste in our
root directory so we don't get any error
and
we'll change the
slide
name instead of
hyph we will add the
underscore
okay now we'll move back to chat jpd and
write a
command and these files are CSV files
not xlsx
file yeah these are CSV files both the
files are CSV files other files are xlsx
files okay so for that we'll write the
command to chat JT
that I have two
files uh with to CSV extension
and they are
named phone
underscore number and the second was
named phone underscore number uncore
2 okay so we have told the J jpt that we
have two files and now we will tell him
to use
Python to add the country
code add
the
country code plus
as string
prefix and that would be adding as a
string prefix else it would only show 91
it won't show plus so we'll see if Chad
jpd understand that or not as string
prefix in both the CSV files
with column name that was
phone
okay now we'll just press
enter and wait for a chat jity to answer
this
query and we'll see how it
responds you can use the P library to
well okay and the prefix to the phone
numbers and modify data
okay do this okay
[Music]
okay
the now we
reading
andone it's adding as typ string okay it
has understood that and to
CSV and this code will in both of f here
I think this will
work we have copied the code let go in
both CS files and the plus time string
to the phone numbers and write the
modifi data back to the Cs files it's
important to know that this will
override the original file so it's Reed
to make a backup of the original
okay uh you would also use the apply
function to add the prefix to the phone
number in the column
okay okay yeah uh we can do this also
the Lambda
function and that's this will also do a
job
first we'll see
this and we will create a
file for this Automation and name it as
country code. py okay and we'll paste
the code
here and run it for you guys but showing
that it has executed
successfully uh yeah it has executed
successfully so we'll
just go back to our
files and
see whether the go+ 91 as in prefix or
not here the
numbers okay the files code only 91 as
the column it's still in the number
format it
hasn't converted into string format uh
we see the second code
also
like yeah it has converted X string okay
Lambda X we'll
see it's working or
not like it has worked uh and the issue
is we
have change the files permission denied
okay we have opened a file we'll close
it and Save
save this and run it
again now it shows it has executed
successfully we'll open the
files and now if we
see it is showing yeah uh now it has
added 2
91s uh so no issues uh the thing is
first we have to transform it into the
string format and then we can add plus
91 as a string to that
string so chat JP misses with the
slightest implementation the
code now moving on uh we'll see this
command later if you want to see how we
can add plus 91 I will tell you how to
write that code
okay so now moving on we will do another
Automation and you would be glad to know
that chat jpt improves the existing code
like uh in the first automation it has
concatenated but it hasn't converted the
concatenated file like it hasn't created
that file it had created the file when
we have returned to it that you forgot
to create that file so chat jpd it
modulates the existing code
also and moving
on
now uh in
any okay we'll open the concatenated _
data not
xlsx and inside this okay we have the
product line so what we will do is we
will change
the
name of the electronic assesses to
electronic equipments and home and
lifestyle to
Lifestyle now we'll automate this
process and we can do this automation
all the files also from January to
December so we'll do that only
okay now here
we will command
is Okay now we'll command the chat jpt
that using
python I
trate
through all the Excel
files in
the directory so we are asking him to
iterate through all the Excel files in
the directory and we will ask him to
replace what was electronic
SSS electronic
accessories see the spelling
elic accessories
okay yeah electronic accesses with
electronic
equipments and we'll also ask
him
equipments okay we'll do equipment only
and home and lifestyle we choos
yeah
and home and
lifestyle
and and change it with
only
lifestyle okay so using python we are
iterating through all the Excel files
and changing these
uh that would be in each Excel file so
we have to be specific with a written
language and now we'll save the modified
workbook
in we'll create another folder and in
that we'll save the
files
okay save
the
modified
file in
the
output
folder and if the folder is not created
we'll ask him to create
it
okay then create
one
hold add it
in okay I don't know why I'm saving this
so I have written the command I will
press enter so that J jpd can process it
and give us the code for
that so it's showing us sorry that was
show showing us uh you can use the OS
Library toate through all the Excel
files and directory the pandas library
to read in the files and make the
changes and to save the modified files
okay here's an example of how you could
do
this now here we imported OS Pand as PD
and it has written the code we'll copy
that this code will iterate through all
the Excel files in the current directory
replace electronic accessories with
electronic equipment and home and
lifestyle with lifestyle in the data
frame and then save the modified files
in the output folder if the sorry if the
output folder doesn't exist the script
will create
it you would also use replace function
to replace values in the column
okay this will WR it through all the
cells in each of the Excel sheet and
replace electronic accessories with
electronic equipment and home and
lifestyle with lifestyle if the cell
value is equal to the respective string
okay we have copied a code and now we
will create a
file
and name it as it trade.
py paste the code here and run it for
you
guys the code has been executed
successfully now we'll
see
we open all the files not all but yeah
we'll open
some that was the previous electronic
assess okay so it hasn't changed in
this okay we will open another
file and see if we code the changes in
that or not
that also States the electronic
accessories so it
hasn't done its
job so move back to
jpd and use this code if it functions
else we'll write back to the chat
jpd
okay
just a second I the we are using the
replace and F in
ex okay so for here we have to import
the
OS
done load underscore
book and for
that import this
it close this
files
okay now we'll
see if we qu our solution or
not no it's showing electronic
accessories and home and lifestyle so
chat jpd
doesn't go the code to change
them so we'll ask him another time and
with a different language this
time Al I don't think it has created the
output
folder it has oh
sorry I'm really sorry what I have done
is my
mistake those were the original files
and we have the product line here and we
have electronic accessories
here and that should be
equipments okay uh we have electronic
and
lifestyle let me see my
command
okay I have asked him to change
electronic asses with electronic
equipment and home lifestyle with
lifestyle so it has changed only
lifestyle let
see
okay
okay uh the E here is small we'll update
that in the
code you can write this back to chat jpt
also but yeah first do
this what are i
showing
not has executed
successfully
okay in the output folder we have the
this number
accessories that's with the capital okay
okay okay okay so this code is giving us
error we'll see the last code we'll copy
that
and
try to use
this close the terminal and run it
again
it has executed successfully now we'll
see the
file whether it has changes or not it
has not now we ask the chat
jpd what have you done
brother using python I through all the
Excel files in the Dory and replace
electronic accessories with electronic
equipment and home and lifestyle with
lifestyle okay need Che file save the
modified modif
[Music]
file okay we ask the same thing once
again to
him and with this electronic accessories
oh
sorry and save the modified
file output folder and get the folder it
doesn't exist
okay
okay same the
mov okay let see once
again
close these
files has executed successfully now
we'll open
it and now we can see that it has
changed to electronic
equipment electronic
equipment yeah now it has executed it
successfully maybe there would be an
error with us while copying it as we
have also created the output folder but
we forgot to see in that folder maybe
that could be the error from our
side now we are done with the changing
of the column names uh the cell names
that was electronic access to electronic
equipments and home and lifestyle to
Lifestyle now we'll do the next
automation
for that first we'll open an Exel
file uh this was in the output
folder we get back to our main directory
and open the file
July and
here here we will filter the Excel file
for gender that is we'll select gender
as female and with the unique values in
column
City and we'll extract the data from
column A to q that would be the whole
data and for each Unique city value
we'll create a new Excel file for each
City and that will contain data only for
that City and for females only and after
that we'll save this file in a folder
named City so we'll give this command to
chat jpt
and here you can also specify the module
you want chat JP to use for the
particular command here we will be
commanding the chat jbt to use the
pandas module and for that we'll write
the command not command in the natural
language we'll give this command to the
chat
jbd and for that we'll write using
Python and
pandas
filter
the okay we will just pick a single
Excel file or we can pick the
concatenated file that is concatenated
underscore
data filter
the
concatenated underscore
data dot Excel
SX
Excel
file and that would be for gender
female and by
the unique values in column
City okay first we'll give the
command by the unique
values
in the
column
City and after that we want to extract
the data from column A to q that is the
whole
sheet extract the
data from the
column A2 q and for each Unique city
value
for each
Unique
city
value now we will extract the data and
now we'll create a new Excel file so for
that also we'll give the command to to J
jpd and we'll write create a new Excel
file and that would be for each
City
okay so we'll write create a
new Excel
file for each
City
containing
data only for
that
City and for
females
okay and save this file in
the city
folder and if
it not being there chat GPT can create
the folder for that
also okay City folder
and naming the each file with the city
name
Okay naming each
file after
the
corresonding
city
okay now
if
the CT folder that is we have written
the small City
okay if the city folder doesn't
exist then create
it before saving the
files
okay now we have given this command to
the chat jpt and it has responded us
with you can use the pandas Library as
we already mentioned to use that to read
in the
concore data. xlsx file and filter the
data for gender female group the data by
the unique values in the city column and
extract the data from the specified
columns for each group and here is an
example so we have put the
code we'll wait till chat jpd
continues
and we can see that the chat GPD has
completed
and we will copy this
code Pro
open
seeed G
female City we make the direct City and
for City Group in female dataout group
by okay City
and you could also use the Asen method
to filter the data frame for female
gender okay first we'll see
this and
for that we will create filter.
py and run the
code it has been executed successfully
so now you'll see that the city folder
has has been created or
not I'm not able to see the city
folder okay it's been
created so we see okay it's been
created man it's still
empty so we'll give
time
okay we quote an
error okay okay we'll pass this error to
J J first and after that we'll see
what's wrong with
this on you are so theor message you're
saying is in getting that the column
name specified in the list are not
present in the data frame it's likely
that the actual column names in the data
frame are different than the ones you
specified in the
list okay we just see the
list that is concatenated
data go
back and see that is
A2
okay it's still
R okay we made a little mistake
here so we'll
just change our
Command yeah this is it and instead of Q
now we'll write R and save and submit
now we'll see what it
would what it would generate for
us we'll close
this
okay let go will F in Excel files filter
the data for females group the data by
the unique values in the city column
create and extract the data from the
column A to R for each Unique city name
and then create a new Excel file for
each City containing data only for that
City and for females files will be sa in
the city folder naming H file after the
corresponding City
okay it's done now we'll copy this
code and paste it here and
see whether this code works for us or
not so it's been executed successfully
now we have moved to the okay it's
executing so we'll give time to the code
let it do it so yeah it's been executed
successfully okay so there were three
cities that was Mand Na and
Yangon and if I show you the
data you could
see there see three cities and it has
created the Excel files with the name of
the Cities only the unique cities and it
has extracted the data for the gender
female now we'll see those
files close
this and
back in the city
folder could see the and laity and the
data is just for the
females so this automation works well
with J
jbt now moving on we will do one more
Automation and that would be to use
Python to identify what is the count of
each payment
mode so for
that I will just get you aware of the
payment modes in our sheet and we'll do
this automation on the concatenated data
sheet only
so this is the payment column and you
can see the mode of payments that is
ewallet cash credit card and these are
repeating so we will use Python to
identify what is the count of each
payment mode from column M column n
sorry and that is from this sheet only
and then we'll create a new sheet and
name it as count. xlsx and write the
count against each payment method so
we'll give this command to our chat
gbt and ask him to write the code for
our
automation so we writing use Python to
identify use Python to
identify what is the count
of
each payment
method
from column and the column was n from
column n and that was in
concatenated con
cated
underscore data do xlsx
sheet
and create a new
named count do
xlsx
and write the
count
against each payment
method
okay now we have given this command to a
chat jpd and we'll see what it offers to
us you can use the Pand library to read
okay that's the same value counts
function to get the count of each V
method okay and you can use the 2XL
method to the data frame to write the
count to a new sheet okay that's good
and he has imported the Panda's library
and create the DF variable in which he
has read the concate file and used
counts function with the payment method
and colal to pay okay the column name is
payment not payment method I think it
would
generate an error for
us
[Music]
so python of each one method from column
n and we will
specify column M and that is named
payment as it has used payment method
here you can
see that it has used a column name as
payment method so we'll specify
this we have to be very specific with
our commands for these automations for
simple task you can use Simple language
like no complex sentences or you have to
mention every detail but but for these
automations you have to use
them now our chat jpd is working with
this and mostly it will deliver us with
the perfect code I hope
so okay
uh it has red and the value count and it
has
exported
reset also the group by function to
group the data the P method and use the
size method
okay okay we'll see
this and
here we will create a file s count.
py and in this file we'll pck B the code
delivered us by the chat
JT we
have executed it it's being executed
we'll wait for
that it's been executed
successfully so we have move back to our
folder and we have to look for
file count file now yeah count
file is this the no it's the okay yeah
it's showing us the mode of payments
that is ewallet cash credit card and the
number of
usage yeah 4
48,3 12 yeah it's 12,000 that was the
whole entry of the concatenated undor
data
xlsx so we have done with this
Automation and now we'll do one last
Automation and first
we'll close all these
files okay and moving back to our jat
GPT and now we will do we will rename
all the 12 Excel files that was January
February to December and we will add the
word uh Car Sales just before the month
name that would we will just add the
prefix before the month name and for
that we'll give the command to the chat
GPD in the natural language and here
only we will change it in the main
directory only as we have the copy of
all these files so for this we'll write
the Quant use
Python
rename all the 12 Excel
files
named
January
February
until
December
okay and that is present in my
directory and what we have to do is we
have
to add uh the word we add Car Sales
okay car sales
in front
of
each in front
of each file
name
okay so what it will do is car sales
uncore January Car Sales uncore February
and so on so we'll wait for the chat gbd
you can use the O library to iterate
through all the Excel files inting then
use the to rename function okay to
rename the files here is an example of
how you could do this go to S and we
have the
months
okay
this code will iterate through all the
Excel files in the current directory and
add carels in front of each file
name and those files would be those only
the months and good it's using the glow
module and you could also use the Glo
mod okay that's the second
code it's the easy one
okay but we'll go with OS
first and get back to our ideally and
name the file as rename do
py and here we'll paste the
code and run
it it's been executed we'll move back
yeah you could see that car sales have
been added to all the
files and with that we have done with
our
automations and if you want you can also
submit your code to chat GPT and ask it
to add commands to your code so that it
could explain you what that line does or
what that function does it would explain
very tediously and if you want you can
also try chat gbd to automate many of
tasks you can automate PowerPoint for
that and do many more tasks with jjpd
and have a look at wide range of e IML
courses by simply learn in collaboration
with top universities across the globe
find the course Link in the description
box now let's open the chart GPD and
check let's refresh this I have already
opened my chart GPD you can just log in
it and then you're good to go so let's
say hell
and
see so it's working completely fine
right now okay so what will we do today
is we'll open our Visual Studio code I
have created one folder which is
Tailwind it's an empty folder you can
just see that so in that folder We'll
add the Tailwind so first let's ask the
chat GPT to help us install or set up
the Tailwind so I'll
write
please set up
the
relent let's
see
okay it's asking us to install nodejs
first and then it's asking us to check
the version of that
okay it's saying to install these
new Pro Piel JavaScript
module to add these component in the CSS
file so this is saying to add this in
the CSS file
okay
[Music]
so let's check whether it is telling us
something useful or
not post CLW Class Auto
fixer
okay okay
okay now simultaneously let's
check the tailin
website how to install
this so here it's saying to install this
command npm install D tailin CSS and
then in it in that project then it's
saying to configure the template part to
add this to your dilin configure file
then it's saying to create a folder
input. GSS and then just start the
process so as of
now chat GPT has not given us the
correct answer it's correct but not up
to the mark as you can clearly see the
commands that are given on the Tailwind
docss official
website uh so according to me many
people thing that uh CH because of chat
jpt the uh so many jobs of the
developers are in the risk because chat
GPT can create websites all of the stuff
so I don't think so according to me it's
not that good it's very good for the uh
helping any developer purpose uh but
it's not that good but let's see we are
in this together so let's check just
open the visual studio code and install
our Tailwind now we'll ask it to create
so many other things so let's see
whether it can create that or not so I
have opened my terminal so many people
also comment us uh that how you could
open the terminal so I just used one
shortcut control+ back to open the
terminal you can also go here and create
create one
terminal okay now I'll paste the line to
install T CSS in my
system so let's wait a couple of minutes
as you can see it's installed in our
system all the packages and modules are
install now it will tell us to init this
project so let's do
that
okay it has successfully created the
configure file now inside the content
we'll copy paste this one as it is
saying to add these line configure your
template part add the part to all your
template file in the file okay so let's
just copy this
thing and paste in the
content now let's save
it okay so now next step is add the
tailin directives to your
CSS
now what we we do here
is let's go back to Studio code and
create a
folder inside
this
that
SRC okay and inside this SRC we'll
create the file input.
CSS here we'll paste the code okay we
haven't copied that code all yet so let
copy let's paste it here it's done
okay so I don't think so again that this
can replace the developers because this
is not the correct way to tell although
it has given us all the steps but any
developer can do the task in a very
short period of time it can just help
any developer but not take the job of
the developer
okay so let's move ahead
and step would
be to go back next step to build the
process let's copy this one and start
the Tailwind CLI build process okay
okay let's copy and paste it here
right as you can see it's done in 273
milliseconds the output. CSS is
generated in this this file folder
right now we just have to use this file
output. CSS
okay let's see
now let's create
a file
here and name it as
index.
HTML okay and inside that I'll write my
Boiler code just pressing shift and one
for the as comination Mark and then the
Boiler code is done so we can change the
name of this and let's write here as
s using CH
un
okay
now one main thing that I wanted to tell
you that I have installed one uh
extension in my system which is the
light server this extension you can
download and this is very helpful
okay let's open this
one now what we'll do is we'll link the
output. CSS file in our html. CSS so for
that I'll write here
link okay and inside this ring I
will or you can just write link and then
click and then write
real
stylesheet
okay to
cut what you'll do is we'll give the
path of the output. GSS for that we WR
dot dot slash
l slash output. CSS it's just showing
go
okay close this link tag and let's save
it and let's just right click and here
you'll see open with live server then
you will install the extension live
server so let's open this one
so this is working completely fine it's
showing us the title website using
J okay or
something I'll write
here
welcome to Simply learn and then let's
save it and you'll see it's showing
welcome to Simply
okay now the next step would be to
create now let's open
our
charb
and here we'll
write create
a
responsive
header
using
let's first copy this
one and
then
okay so let's see whether it can give us
a right answer this time we
can
let's
see okay it's giving us the code now for
the
[Music]
header
okay
so it is showing us in the above code we
use tailin CSS classes to style the
header we set the background color to
Gray This one is the property of gray
color and then the text color would be a
white color in that n bar inside the
header we have a n element with the flex
and justify between okay classes to
horizontal Center the element space them
out evenly okay fine we also use PX4 and
py3 to add pedding to the navigation bar
cool for the mobile menu we used a
button with the MD hidden class to hide
it
on okay let's see the code now okay now
let's copy this HTML file let it write
everything so here we don't need this
one so let's delete this and let's here
write header and let's comment it
down this okay let's P the code and
check whether
it's let's save it and let's go back to
our
file so this is what CH gbt created for
us it's looking very good actually so
let's inspect
it and let's see is it responsive or not
so this is completely responsive
guys okay very good
yeah
so this is really very good okay on
Surface do s 20 Ultra this is what will
show on the mobiles okay now we'll go
back to the chat gbt and let's close
this one
and stop generating and let's here right
create
the SA ction
using
T CSS now let's see something went
wrong
okay let's see let's first copy this one
and we
this and let's see how will create the
hero section using ta Me
cases so it has created this Nar really
very good I didn't expect this from JT
but it's really really looking very good
it's simple and you can add these to
another Pages just using the anchor tag
there we can just give the path so I'll
show you www.
[Music]
simply. so this this one is
okay so whenever I click on this one it
will redirect us to the simply L but the
URL is wrong we can just go back to
Simply
learn.com and let's copy
the and let's go back to
code and let's here right the URL okay
save it and let's see
yeah this is how this works let's close
this one okay now let's see what is the
code okay let's copy this code and let's
see how this is working so it is also
giving us the complete code uh how it's
working how this step is working and all
as you can see it's giving us the max W
with 7 into one utility sets as Max
width for the container to 7 XL which is
12 112 RM or 7092 pixels it's giving us
all the explanation for the code it has
written for us so let's check it and
after the header I'll paste that code
and let's save it and
see okay this is really very good
guys yeah I didn't expect this from CH
gbt but it's looking very good
so U till if I am a developer so if I
had to write this much of code it'll
take me around 2 three hours at least
but with the help of chat gbt it only
created in 5 10
minutes this is very good actually now
let's open the chart GPT again and here
we'll create
a information
section okay let's
information
section
using
tail let's see
now till now it's working really very
good now it is writing a code for us so
as you can
see
again very
good now let's copy this one and paste
it under
this save it and let's check so this is
the information section this has created
for
us right important information location
off his ours contactors and all right we
can also regenerate it for something
else okay now we it will create
something else for
us
right if you don't like something we can
just regenerate and create another one
so let just let's copy this
one now it's telling us everything about
the code and here after that I'll write
this and save it let's check what's this
okay this is the information section it
has created for us that this is
something CH data and if you don't like
this one also you can again regenerate
the response this is really an amazing
feature of char gbt okay so now it's
creating the third option we can
countlessly ask him to uh create again
and again for us the
response let's copy this one okay and
let's remove all of it
because it's looking very
clumsy now let's see okay this
information section is information
section wel come to our website this is
what it's
written
okay now let's ask him to create
something else
okay let's copy this text create
informative and paste it using Tailwind
with one image I'll check whether it can
response to my things if I want to
create one image on the left or right
side and then the text on the other side
let's see whether it can create it for
us or not okay create informative
section using CH GT with one image on
the right side and the text on
the left
now let's
see whether it can create that or not
for us right it's just an simple command
so we'll check whether it can create or
add the
image okay you classes but text
but okay it took the image class
also and it's taking the source from an
API called unsplash I have covered this
unsplash API on my previous videos okay
okay now let's copy this and paste it on
our code let's delete this one and paste
this one on the
website okay so the image is quite large
we can reduce the sizes but in the
starting only I have told you I'll not
add anything in the code so I'm not
doing anything in the code right so we
can change the size it's really good as
I have told him to add the image on the
right side and the text on the left side
that's doing the same for the user so
this is really very helpful for the
developer but as I have already told you
it will cannot replace the developers
because uh I the developer I only knows
how to uh do things as I have showed you
that it has given me so many wrong
answers before that before this one this
has given me three answers but it was
not up to the mark so I had to told him
that to uh create uh like this image on
the right and I've explained it to uh
chart GPT then it created this one for
us okay and whenever I'll refresh this
page the image will get changed this is
the unlash API how this works okay we
can change the images
also this is random just write
here coding okay now you will see the
images that will come here
okay let's
see
let's check
it that's not taking any other
name yeah don't know it's not working
but let's not waste time on this random
is also
fine till now it's looking really very
good okay
now the next step would be to add the
service section okay so let's ask CHP to
create service section for us
okay
using now let's
see
it's
coming
okay the class the SI of the bo
one really very
good so look how beautifully it has been
created
right
yeah
okay let's
see it's done now let's copy the code
and go to our
editor and
here we write this code and then space
it let's
check okay so it's not a align straight
but we can align it so it's showing us
that the services that this website is
providing what we offer and this is some
junk data web design web marketing and
all so let's check whether it
is
yeah okay so what this one is doing here
is it's using
only three classes it is using
and the center
Center these all are using the same
class but let's find out why the image
it is
coming like
that
right you can align
it you guys want me to align this we can
align this right okay
so let's just align one it's just one
line okay we can align that so let's dig
deep into this
code
okay this image
classes
okay
image same justify Center and then it's
using the flex shring
function rounded
large
okay the wi
56 let's make it 50 and
[Music]
check and let's go back to the code
the size of this
first
change okay let's go back to the Chart
again again regenerate the new response
and let's see how the second response is
looking right let's w a couple of
seconds
more okay let's see the response that it
is
creating we need a minimalist design
okay I will just observing the code
and see how it's
looking you can also change the color of
the customiz it uh this website on our
own but it's really very good I'm really
impressed with this this really will
help developers creating
websites
okay let's go back
to still creating
after that we'll create the about
section for the page
okay okay it's again giving us that
design and all
part
great if I'll tell Char GT to create uh
this service section and this is my
requirement and all it will definitely
create that I guess now
I am impressed really impressed with the
code clean code it's
writing and it's also responsive I
haven't told it to create the responsive
uh code but it's really very good it's
the responsive I I show
you inspect I was just seeing that only
whether it is responsive or not if
you'll see okay let me just cut this
card let's just
okay yeah so this is how we'll check the
responsive take and
let's see that these three uh home about
contacts are
vanished
and this is the header part that we
created and then the one is the nbar
this is the information
section and services section is also
there so this is all
responsive
okay so we'll check how it's looking on
Samsung
xs2 this is how it's
looking really
good yeah let's move on to the code copy
this code and coming back to the code
editer let's delete this
section
okay now let's paste it and
C
okay it's giving us an
error this is what it created for us
it's I guess uh little
less
or it was already writing the code and I
stopped it's fine it's not its mistake
let's stop and regenerate the
response let's copy this again
coming back to
the
Chart working let's refresh CH GP
again service section let's
see it's really fast
now
okay let's observe this one first uh our
services what we offer
web design there must some lines about
digital marketing and I'm thinking there
is
also uh one part which I cut
down not Char mistake it was mine
because I stop generating the
response
okay really good let's copy this TT now
and paste it
under and let's do this and paste
it let's check it this
time
so this is how this one is looking now
this is also really looking very good we
can decrease the size of this image do
not worry about that uh this is the
service our services and some Jun data
here we can write this uh website is
providing this and that okay service one
that we we provide this service we
provide this service and we provide this
service okay this is all about
that right really very good really very
good it's really very good okay you can
change everything from it customize it
on our our needs
thing let's just go back okay this one
is looking good okay now let's ask Char
GPD to create the about page for us so
we'll write
create so I think uh meanwhile it's
writing the code for us I wanted to tell
you that chat is great for uh for
everyone but as I know the code how this
code is working I know what is section
what is Dev class and what are the
function this grid system that's using
Max withd uh it's using the Excel
function I know everything about it and
if you are a fresher or you don't know
about anything about the coding uh I
think you should first uh know about the
language or the framework then only ask
uh this to char
or take help from the Chad right if you
don't know about the language or the
framework and you'll just tell Char to
create this and this for us it's easy it
will create for you but uh it will not
uh help you in your future so according
to me
just uh use it to learn not to work okay
so let's move
ahead and the path is
given
okay it was again managed let's ask it
again
responsive
about
section
using
T okay I just m but it is very
intelligent I misspelled the Tailwind
spelling and then it corrected it very
good so this is not the complete code
for the about page uh I ask it
to let's see whether it will take this
command or
not right great so let's
see after this about section we'll
create this contact page and then
we'll create fin this website
right so this is really very helpful for
the developers I must
say so let's copy this
and code and paste it under this
section
okay this is how the about pages
looking really very good the image size
is 500 into 500 it's really very big so
we can change the size of the
image let's
see is
that right
and the image will not come
again
okay let's just delete this
Source Cy the
unlash API for the random
image
right that command is really really
useful okay I have go to add
that
yeah yeah this is how this about is
looking really very good guys really
very good if I tell Char to create this
on the right side or this image I want
on the left hand side or right hand side
it will definitely do for us as I have
given him the uh task in this section
information section it definitely work
so I must say it's really very good so
now let's move on to
the contact page
okay let's here write
create create a
responsive
contact
Section
[Music]
using
D and I'll ask him to do add some
sections for us so let's see whether it
can take up that or
not okay let's give it in a second shot
let's first see how is the contact
Section is looking then we'll tell him
to improvise that
so it's just taking a section class
inside that section class it's using
some classes which is fle RAB and all
and it's giving
us it's really
good let's copy this text again and
paste it
here
so the contact dust is also looking very
good get in touch and then it will
redirect us to
the that really good really the images
sizes are uh large but we can reduce it
it's not a big deal but it's all looking
very good right so one thing is left is
the footer part the let's ask it to
create a footer for us now this is the
last and final step for
this
create the
putter
section
using this is really very good looking
very good let's add
the
Splash and
then use it
here
okay so this is how it's looking now so
overall if I see it really given us a
good good output really so uh I will say
chart gbt can only help us that's it as
this code that is created by chat GPT
for us we can't use it directly this
structure that chat GPT created for us
is good but we need to add so many
things before deploying it right uh if
I'll see this one we need to add this uh
uh services in the center and we need to
uh uh AR the text and the services we
need to change the size of the services
if uh the client wants it uh
horizontally then we have to change that
we need to change this image size as in
front of you I change this email sizes I
use the different apis so overall it's
very good but there uh is so many things
uh that we have to do okay
and for that developers are
needed hello everyone and welcome back
to another video by simply learn my name
is anubhab and today I'll be talking
about chat GPT for web development and
tell you guys that you can create your
own website using chat GPT even if you
don't know how to code chat GPT is an
advanced language model based on GPT 3.5
architecture
and it can be incredibly useful for web
development projects but before I tell
you more about web development with ch
gbt if you want to become a software
developer then consider our
post-graduate program by keltech in
fullstack web development by simply
learn and master those necessary skills
the link or to the course will be in the
description box below and pin comment
you can also reach out to us on the
numbers that are given below and learn
more about the program so let me tell
you what chart GPT is chart GPT is a
machine model that generates humanik
text responses it's been generated on a
massive data set of text and can
generate highly accurate responses to a
wide range of queries but how can CH gbt
be used for web development there are
number of ways for example CH gbt can
generate website content improving SEO
and boosting engagement chat GPT can
also be used to create chat boards that
can interact with customers in a natural
and engaging way now let's look at some
of the real life examples of how chart
GPT has been used for web development so
for example if I ask chart GPT to create
a e-commerce website for me it will
easily create it so let's see
it please create a
website for me in
HTML and CSS this so there is one point
that I wanted to tell you guys if you
want to ask chat jpt for anything just
give good description about it so it can
give you a good response if I tell you
tell it more about my uh requirements it
will generate good uh quality of product
okay so let me tell it please create a
website for me in cssn
HTML that
should
[Music]
some
col like
orange and
blue
right
and where I'm
selling okay now lay wait for the
response of char gbt it will create uh
the things the code okay now it's
writing the HTML code
right so I'll tell you more about it
like for example e-commerce sites use
Char GB to generate product descriptions
improving their SE and uh driving sales
customer service team use CH GPT to
create automated chat boards that can
help customers with common queries and
there are so many other things also like
uh content creators also use chart GPT
to generate amazing content for their
website right so let's wait a couple of
minutes more until it gets completed
right so as you can see it's giving us a
proper response of
everything as it created this file for
us and we can just easily copy it from
here and I have logged into my online
editor you can open any editor if you
want
one so this is the online editor that
I'm working on right now I'll clean
this so as you can see e-commerce
website is ready right so this is a very
basic website but CH GPT has created
this for us it's a very easy website
like very basic but as the instructions
that I gave it it applied all the things
that it's using yellow color but I asked
for orange but it's fine I ask for blue
color so this is also fine but before
asking chart gbt you should know a
little bit about coding right so in H1
tag here you have to write the heading
it's the header tag inside that it's the
H1 The Heading
one okay so here I'll write my website
name I'll write
website and then you can see see let
Jo website right so how can you use CH
GPT for your own development projects
first you have to familiar yourself with
the programming languages and tools that
are compatible with Char gbt and it will
only knows the data until
2021 so once you are done that you can
experience with Char gbt to see how it
can benefit your
project right if I I ask him to create
wait I'll show you guys some of the
things that CH gbt can
do create a
header so I've told gbt to create a
header and make it functional and also
add page product page and contact us
page make it a little more I WR make it
attractive right so let's see
it's will write us a code for that so
until then let me tell you the use
cases so as I already mentioned chat GPT
has already proven its values in various
web development scenarios for example
e-commerce platform use Char GPD to
generate product descriptions boosting
their search engine optimization and
driving more sales customer service team
employ CH GPT to build Interactive chat
boards that provides instant and
accurate responses to customer queries
enhancing the overall user experience so
optimize the generated content from SEO
ensures that the text generated by CH
GPT aligns with relevant keywords and
follow SEO best practices right so with
the help of char GPT SEO things this can
help improve your website visibility in
search engine results and it can create
natural and authentic chatboard
experience so when using chat gbd to
develop chat boards focus on creating
conversation that feels like human use
context and personalization to ensure
user engagement and build trust leverage
CH GPT for customer engagement Beyond
generating content right chat GPT can
help engage user on your website also
for instance you can use it to develop
interactivity and so many other things
okay so now let's see what chat GPT has
created for us right let's copy this and
paste it on the online editor that I
have showed
you I don't recommend using uh online
editor you can have a visual studio code
it's very good so it doesn't have any
CSS I yes yeah add your customer Uh
custom styles for product pages here
yeah so as I know we have to write the
CSS here but it's fine I have to show
you something different so as I told it
to create a e-commerce website so it
give given its name as welcome to
e-commerce website but we can change it
from here the title of the website we
can change it right and I have told it
to create home product and and contact
page right as I have showed you so it
has created the same thing that I have
told Char to create for me as in the
products page there's no things added
right now but we can add it add your
products and their details here as it's
written in the code also I guess yeah in
the section part we can add our product
and the things that we want right now
let's ask chgb to
create
Circle create five Circle
different
radius or 20
[Music]
pixels
to pixel right
and F
and blue
and
orange now let's see whether it can
create five circles of different radius
for us or not right and now it's writing
the HTML file for
us let's wait a couple of seconds to see
whether it can create so it given us the
things we want one but I don't think so
it has different uh radius okay as you
can see in the CSS part it is given
everything a different height and width
let's copy the CSS first or HTML
anything you want and we'll paste it on
the online editor let's go again and
copy the HTML part also and paste it
here now we will will down and as you
can see the first circle is small and
then the last one is the largest one
right so as you have given it the chart
GPT the instructions that I want this
thing or that thing it has created the
same thing that I told him to do right
so it's all about instructions but as I
know that this is width and height this
is very simple thing but when you'll uh
code on python or JavaScript or Java
it'll be a very complex things so I
recommend first learn the language and
then use charity to improve it right so
many developers and programmers use CH
digity to enhance their productivity not
to learn it so it's very good for
learning purpose also if I tell
it I want to
learn Java I say
Java
from where
should
start learning
it give
me
some
princes
and
some
web
sides from
where I can
start with
the links of them right so I asked Char
to tell me from where should I start
learning the HT Java so it's now telling
that's great Java is a popular
programming language as there are many
resources available to help you learn it
here are some of the website and
resources where you can start learning
Java right so it's giving me Oracle Java
tutorial it's very good to learn Java
from uh Java programming on course era
it's giving some of the renowned Java
certification courses but I recommend
you to take our Java certification
fullstack Java certification the link
will be in the description box for that
it's a very good certification for um
newly uh starting developer or
programmer or experience one also so
from there you will start learning Java
from scratch so that is also very good
you can also check it out right so as I
told it to give me the instructions from
how to learn Java so it just gave me
everything with the links right so
now get
to give me
any projects
ideas
for react
J
right so now it's telling me uh you can
create a project on react for from
starting from Todo list which is a very
basic app when you start learning any
language you start it by from too list
only or too app whatever you say next
one is weather app movie Library which
is also very good practice for Library
uh for react Developers to start
learning react from and the e-commerce
store except founder chat
application and these are the 10
projects that they uh the CH gbt told us
to learn right so it's very good you can
ask it anything if you don't know
anything like uh I'll tell you rejs
right I don't know
thing about
reactjs
please about
it so I told it I don't know anything
about reactjs I know about reactjs but
it's like I want to see what it's saying
you can also check out the projects that
I have created on react on this simply
learns YouTube channel so uh it's saying
everything certainly reactjs is a
popular JavaScript library for building
user interfaces it was developed by
Facebook and it is widely used for
building single page application it's a
dyamic application so some of the key
points of react component based
architecture virtual Dom and declarative
syntax unidirectional data flow react
Hooks and so many other things so as you
don't know anything about react it will
tell you to get started with react you
can begin by learning fundamentals of
JavaScript and familiarize uh yourself
with HTML and CSS once you have a good
understanding of these Technologies you
can explore reactjs by following
tutorials reading documentation I
recommend documation because it's very
good you will get a deep understanding
of that then move to tutorials and all
and build small projects it is also very
good thing start from uh learning from
the projects you'll learn more react
official document is here so excellent
resource to learn reacts from scratch
additionally there are various online
courses tutorials and YouTube channel
dedicated to teaching learning reactjs
such as react course on these platforms
and you can also learn react from our
YouTube channel remember to to practice
regularly build projects to refine uh
your learning and leverage the reactjs
community for support and guidance as
technology advances in all aspects of
Our Lives programming has become
increasingly important it is used in
many fields and industries including
software development G gaming and
entertainment education scientific
research web development and many more
so needless to say the demand for
programming and coding in the IT
industry will probably keep increasing
for the foreseeable future but where
does chat open ai's popular language
model fall in this chain that's exactly
what we are focusing on in this today's
video as I said earlier programming is
utilized in many domains like web
development robotics mobile development
machine learning and so on so how how
can a program achieve maximum code
efficiency nowadays we have eii based
tools like charab to make our
programming experience more efficient
although there are several coding
resources platforms such as stack
Overflow and GitHub where programmers
can find solutions to their technical
programming questions charity stands out
from the competition because of its
quick response time usability and
support for numerous languages among
many other benefits now let's first
discuss how chip Works chip generates
responses to the text in input using a
method called Transformer architecture a
large volume of text is fed into the
chat GPT from various sources including
books websites and other social media
platforms the model then uses this
information to forecast the following
word in a phrase based on the words that
came before it the charity systems
allows users to enter text or queries
and then the system uses its training
data and algorithms to produce the right
answer the answer is created after the
input text has been examined and the
pattern most likely to match the input
have been identified using the training
data in short chity is designed to
respond to queries logically and command
more quickly and accurately but why do
programmers use Char on a regular basis
chip assists programmers by offering
programming related answers and
solutions and helping them improve their
skills beside that Char is utilized for
code generation code completion code
review and a natural language interface
let us understand each in detail chity
is trained to generate the code of or
even the entire program described in the
natural language specified by what they
want a program to do and then charab
could generate the relevant code look at
the example of how Char GPT generates
the code so now open the chpt and you
can type any program that you want chpt
to generate so I will give write a palum
program in Java so here you can type
write
a
palum program in
Java so using Java programming language
it should generate the whole
program so as you can see it has
generated the program so it has used a
class name called palum Checker and it
has used e pandrum as a method name and
also it will give the explanation on the
program so you can see here why it is
explaining why e pandrum is used as a
method and U it also explains means the
for Loop if a condition and so on next
we have code completion charity is
trained to generate Snippets of code or
even fully fledged programs it can
generate a list of possible code
completion depending on the context of
the users incomplete piece of Code by
automatically producing the entire code
it can help the developers save time and
minimize errors next let's see the
example of code completion using chity
so even if the program is explained in
natural language CH GPT will generate
the proper code and give the complete
code so let's type
here using a
function write a
program to
convert the
string in
uppercase so using which language let's
keep using C
programming and enter it once again
again so as you can see we have just
said that using a function write a
program to convert the string in upper
case so using C programming language and
using C programming language it has used
function and you know this is the
function convert to uppercase and has
given the complete code for string or to
convert a string in uppercase and also
it gave the explanation here the convert
to uppercase function Tak a pointer to a
string as its argument and then iterates
over each character in the string using
a for Loop so it explained why for Loop
is used why two upper is used and why
the method convert to uppercase is used
everything so let's say uh we'll give
one piece of code like
void to
Upper car s Str
so as you can see we just gave the
method to Upper and it's generating the
complete code so this is how Char works
for code completion next code review
charity can analyze code identify the
bugs or errors in the program and
further help resolve them it allows
developers to fix errors more quickly so
now let's have a look at the example of
code review so in this example charity
will review the code so even if the code
has some mistake it will give the proper
output let's say we have given the
example here so we give the function or
a method called
upper and here we are giving the keyword
called upper so it should check whether
this piece of code is proper or is there
any mistake in
this so as I said uh it's saying that
that the given code appears to have
logical error as the function upper is
being called recursively on itself
inside the loop so instead of giving two
upper we just give upper here right so
using the keyword two upper only then
the string can be converted to uppercase
so here we gave just upper so it says
that it is having this piece of code is
having a logical error and it gives a
proper code for
us so I hope it's clear and then we have
natural language interface with the use
of chat GPT a software application can
be given a natural language user
interface that enables users to
communicate with it through natural
language instructions rather than
through conventional user interfaces
next let's see how Taj helps the
programmers for natural language
interface so let's say we'll give
here
create a software
application where
the
user asked to
enter
credential for the too
app
enter so as you can see the Char will
give the steps so it can provide you
with an outlet for creating a software
applications that requires the user to
enter credential for a to-do app so here
it is few steps that we need to follow
to do a to-do
app so it's giving the explanation step
by
step
so it says that determine the
programming language and framework then
set up the database to store the user
information and then create the
registration page and then finally
create the login page as well and once
the user is successfully logged in um
you know it will have the options like
add edit and delete task as well and
then finally implement the security
measures to you know protect your
passwords and then test the application
to ensure that it works as intended and
the user data is being stored and
retrieved correctly so it gives the
steps of how it has to be developed have
a look at wide range of e IML courses by
simply learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe find the
cost Link in the description
box I'm sure you all are aware of chity
at this point the Revolutionary new AI
based chatbot developed by open AI has
has taken the World by storm thanks to
its near lifelike responses and a very
intricate pattern of answers we have
never seen this level of expertise from
a chatbot before which really made us
think to what extent can we push it
there are many questions on lead code
that even the most experienced
programmers have difficulty answering so
we wanted to see how far chat gbd can
take us have we finally reached the
stage where AI is going to replace us
let's find out so basically here we will
be listing 10 really difficult questions
that we found on lead code popularly
asked while hiring and other Superior
examinations and see if chat GPD can
actually answer or solve those difficult
questions or not but before you like to
watch more such interesting videos then
do subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's get
started oh here is the lead code let's
see uh in our list which is the first
question that we are going to implement
in our chat G PD and see if it's able to
solve it or not mainly we'll focus on
hard category questions only
so according to my research there's a
question of
median of two sorted
arrays so as you can see the success
rate is
35.7% so let's see if the chart is able
to do this question so first let us go
through the
question
okay press enter let's see what it first
returns
uh on a one approach to solving this
problem is to use a modified binary
search algorithm to find the median of
the two sorted areas so right now it's
particularly giving the logic which we
can actually imply to solve this
question and uh this is a good about the
chat GPD is that before uh giving the
code it's actually explaining how they
are putting the logic in together in the
code so probably you can use this logic
to create your own program but let's see
how sensible this code
is quite a lendy
program in Python so if you are looking
for your Solutions on chat gbd you can
always opt out or you know mention the
specific program you want the code in so
okay it's it's also gives that okay that
the time complexity will be o log Min m
or n so so let's see if
it the case or
not so we have copied it and we'll
quickly paste it over
here as you can
see uh as we know that python is uh very
sensitive towards its uh syntax and you
can see the indentation over here is
perfect but here it's not so I feel that
something like this is something with
lead code so let me just quickly Rectify
this you can see I have cleared out the
indentation issue and let's just quickly
run this program so that we can get an
idea if this is the correct
program uh now you can see here we have
an error let's see copy this and see
what chart GPD has to say for
this
so if you remember when we actually saw
this question there were three arguments
passed through this function which was
self nums one and nums 2 ask GPT if it
can write the code with self argument
and see if it's
correct wait that if it can pass pass a
self argument through that function and
see if it can generate a new
code okay now it has cleared that yes it
takes three
arguments
let's this
code it over here again I think we will
have to go through the indent ation
process oh no this time it's fine okay
so now quickly run this program let's
see if this time it passes all the test
cases or
not I think it doesn't need because the
class is already mentioned over
here uh
yeah
okay the run time is 35 Ms and as we can
see case one and case two is definitely
passed
so let us see
if this code can pass all the desk cases
internally mentioned in this question
now you can see the first three cases
are actually accepted but the other
three are not there's a runtime
error
so the first question in our list Jad
GPT was unable to solve so let's move on
to our next
question that is zigzag conversion
now let me quickly search for
it this is the question here also you
can see the success rate is definitely
below 50 and uh the difficulty level is
medium so the hard one Char GP was not
able to solve let's see if this can be
done so it will give a string that will
be written in a zigzag pattern on a
given number of rows and uh then you
have to read the line in a certain as
you can see over
here we have to write the code that will
take a string and make this conversion
given in a number of
rows this also me a certain amount of
certific uh repeat do also given a
certain specifications that we exactly
want so this time we'll make sure that
we are mentioning
everything so let's quickly copy
this
yeah
okay now that we have mentioned all the
specifications uh let me
quickly
Fe and past it now let's see what code
it has to
generate it's implementing the code in
C++ so meanwhile it's generating the
code let's
quickly the code oh it's already C++
okay okay it's also suggesting that we
can definitely use Python and
Java and it's generating an alternative
code as well for
us that's
sharp just quickly copy this
[Music]
code a one I think it's uh okay so it's
generating in uh
Java
it's generating we'll definitely have a
look at its alternative codes as well
let's quickly have a look at what it has
to C++ one the first code generated by
it uh is correct or
not okay copy the
code pasted over
here
dilation
error okay
okay 28
okay so
let's this
error the one thing
definitely this time we have mentioned
all the constraints criteria
specifications that we wanted in our
code but again
charge questions we have implemented
till
now let's see if it has any success rate
in
further
okay it seems
okay okay now it is okay so this time it
is uh generating the solution or
considering the error in
Java let uh see what it has to say in
Java and we'll make it specific that the
error was in C++ program so generates
the correct
code plus plus
program
what it has to
say
uh see so this error is something
related to the compiler
and now it is giving the updated code in
C++ is the correct one or
not she apologizing for making errors in
their
Solutions quite
fascinating
uh
yeah paste the code over here
I don't see there's a lot of difference
or changes over here let's see if it
runs or
not let me see if all the braces are
covered over here or
not
I think it's missing a
brace
okay so there was a syntax error one
brace was
missing um I
don't B
that definitely something with the code
but okay we can give that to chat gbt it
was partially lead codes issue because
we were copying still it was not giving
the error that there is a brace
missing as passed the first three cases
mentioned over here and the run time is
3 Ms now just let us submit this code
and see if it passes all the rest of the
cases or not minded this time we have
actually mentioned all the constraint
so let's see if this has
into okay so this time it has passed all
the test cases but still my conclusion
with this question is uh it was still
not able to generate the solution in one
go uh but still I can give that to char
GPT because the first error that we
faced was more of a lead CES issue
because it was something with
compile and charp was able to give a
proper oh now let's go back to our
problems
list so right now the score is one in
one it was unable to solve one question
and one not so let's have a look at the
third question and see if that brings
any difference to the Chart
gpts scoreboard right now or not
third question that we are going to deal
with is
substring
with concatenation of all words this is
in the category again and the success
success rate is
31.1% which is even lesser than the
first question that we faced which was
median of the two sorted Aras
we trying here we are actually trying to
cover all the Spectra the huge Spectra
of different types of uh questions and
you know categories available in coding
and uh to give you an idea of
how beneficial Char GPT can be for you
to solve difficult questions which can
be helpful for your interview base
in companies or you you can say well
established companies or M companies so
here this video is specifically for you
to give an idea that whether you can use
it for your benefit and you know to get
an idea or you can actually uh compare
it with
yours uh and you can get a you know
wider range of different types of
approaches to a certain
question so let's start with the third
question
is that you're given a string and an
array of strings probably words and all
the strings of words are of the same
length now a concatenated substring in s
is a substring that contains all the
strings of any permutation of words
concatenated here you can see it's given
an example that that if words has AB B
CD EF then AB CD EF basically uh has
done all the permutation and
combinations that can be done using that
specific
array
uh and that AC CD BF is not a
concatenated substring because it is not
the concatenation of any permutation of
words so we have to basically return the
starting indices of all the concatenated
substring in the a
string also you can choose any order for
it here it has also given uh two
examples for you
to understand the question in a better
perspective
now uh copy this question and see
if what programming language adity
chooses to answer this
time
start with new chart
again copy these
constraints
okay it's just a
question okay this is the solution that
we are getting right now you requested a
model that is not compatible with this
engine please contact us through our
help center at
help doop for further questions let me
just quickly refresh it if it has
something to do with the you know demand
also sometimes it happens that the
console is very busy and you're unable
to
implement uh your task in it so again
let's
quickly paste it over
here we want a code write a
code to return
now this
enter definitely it's not giving the
same error let's see this time it
charger has anything to give as a
solution
okay so it's generating the code in
Python more thing every time charab
doesn't follows a similar pattern as you
can see in the first question it
explained the logic first and uh then
implemented the code second time it just
gave you the approach not the logic and
then implemented the code in multiple
languages uh first choosing for
C++ and this time it's state of a EV for
the code so definitely we can say that
it has some different styles of
generating their code and explaining the
code I think it depends on the
understanding how they want the code to
be presented in front of the user and to
give the perspective that if the code is
understandable or not and if the code
has multiple approaches I think charity
is capable to capable enough to give
that so that the code is generated let's
quickly copy
it
and paste it over
here I feel the indentation issue is
going to be
there it was not
there
okay
if probably I think if we back
space sure let me quickly Rectify this
and
I'll so you once the indentations
are
e
the indentation is corrected now uh
let's let's have a look at the code if
it's correct or not let's quickly run
it definitely it has given our first
syntax error again I can see that even
specific video question it definitely
goes to at least one error which is
mainly the syntax
one sure if that is something with the
lead code or you know with
the chart GPT code
generation
okay that we have given the error okay
it seems that the error is caused by the
use of type hints the function type
hints were introduced and the version we
using is lower than that okay so
basically it's generating now in the
python version uh probably this code
is well suited for different version of
python let's change it then and see if
that
helps
it is actually generating the code
okay again given the I think it's again
something with the
self
uhon one the new code generated is
here we definitely come back to that
error and have a look at the Python 3
code
also uh first let's copy this code
and
and giving the same
[Music]
error here and see what it has to
say uh you know every time the charg
generates the pyth code we
cannot ever takes self as an argument
but the lead do as you can see when we
start the code it's already mentioned
what arguments we need to pass from that
particular function so I think that is
something with the lead code
so that what all arguments it's passing
even though we have mentioned everything
this time we have mentioned all the
constraints we have mentioned all the uh
necessary
specifications that we want in the code
even then the code is not correct in the
one go so probably I'll get this point
to GPT it's something with the lead code
because it's passing that parameter and
everything we have to mention that
parameter pretty much when we do the
charge abity is able to solve the
question so let's see what let me uh
actually mention
that
pass uh self parameter self argument
from that parameters one of make it a
one of the
parameters
processing
that yes self can be passed as the first
argument to the given function now let's
see if that it's able to give the
correct solution or not again we can see
it's uh generating the code in you
know Python
3 but we can give that to char GPD that
either it uses python or Python 3 the
error is with the self argument so once
we mention that error and when we
mention that specification that that if
charb can pass self argument through
that particular function in that code
the solution is pretty
much right so here it's also
implementing and giving the
answer okay it also has mentioned that
uh it's important to mention import
imported list and counter so
okay just copy this because again there
will be a lot of uh ination
issues okay now that we have
it let copy the
code already mentioned so yeah we'll
just
copy it from the
[Music]
function paste
it run this code and see if if it has
the solution in it or
not yeah there is an indentation
issue let
me
again as you can see it is able to pass
all the test cases here and the run time
is 28
Ms now let us submit this question and
see if it is able to pass other test
cases or
not accepted so it is able to pass all
the test cases and uh I think this is
something with lead code again uh
whenever we are generating the python
code we are actually passing self
argument uh in lead code but chart G is
not assuming it so this solution is
definitely correct uh even though we are
specifying everything we will have to be
more specific that we have to run one
more argument uh from the function so
that it you know generates the solution
in one go so let us uh try that in our
next next
question but we can definitely see chart
jbd was able to solve this so now the
scoreboard is
211 uh among the three questions it is
definitely able to solve two questions
even in the first question it was able
to generate a correct solution but it
was not that accurate to pass all the
test
cases to our question list
the next that we are going to cover is
in
Queens category but still the success
rate is 63% over here again a new genre
of question we are covering over here
let us see
if solve it or not but definitely the
success rate shows that many people were
able to do it definitely more than half
of people who have attempted it so let's
see if the question can this AI can beat
that or
not so uh I have coped this question
this question mentions that the nend
Queen's puzzle is the problem of placing
n Queens on an N into to N Chess board
such that no two queens attack each
other given an integer n return all
distinct solutions to the in Queen
puzzle so basically n is any given
number and you have to create a puzzle
of n into n and you have to arrange all
the Queens in such uh you know way also
the number of Queens in the board will
be equal to
the in and in such a way that it is not
able to attack each other in any case
po it this part of the
question and the constraint is just
one let
me that it will be easier to keep a
track of uh what all questions CH gbt is
able to
solve
so these questions are very popular uh
in
interviews uh whenever you actually go
to technical rounds and uh for
prestigious companies these questions
are very popular uh they are considered
as very uh suitable questions to check
uh to check your you know IQ and to
check your potential that how well aware
you are towards your coding
potential that we have pressed enter it
is giving the logic it is going to
implement in its code one approach to
solve the end Queen's puzzle is to use
backtracking idea is to start by placing
a queen in the First Column of the first
row so let's see if the Cod is again
capable to you know solve it not again
it's giving the python
code generating the code let us quickly
see whether it's python or Python
3 Pon Python
okay once the code is generated I'll
also write that you need to pass one
more argument from the main function uh
that is self and uh let let it generate
the code again and see that code can run
in one go or
not
mentioned what I want and let us see
sure here's an example of how you can
pass an additional parameter self let's
see if it
suits the code or or
not
the solve end Queen function is a method
of the end Queen's class and it takes
self as its first parameter followed by
the integer n so yes this solution does
take self as a parameter so let's see if
this can run in one go or not because
this time we have already covered the
most uh frequently generated error which
is syntax error of not mentioning
parameter
self let me see the indentation if it's
correct or
not this time uh let us quickly run
this
plus okay there you go now you can see
that it has actually run the code in one
go and all the test cases are passed in
one go even the run time is 39 Ms so
definitely CH gbt is able able to
provide the solutions the Logics in a
proper manner it's just that we have to
be more specific with what we want
exactly uh from chat gbt right now we
can see that it has been able to
successfully generate four out of five
uh questions that we have actually
implemented till now out of which four
are from hard
category let us submit this code and see
if it also covers all the test cases in
intern fed in for this question just a
second I think I will have to submit it
again here you go it has accepted all
the test cases and this question is done
by Char GPT it has actually
implemented question that we are going
to cover till now I can say Char GB has
taken the lead
it is pretty much able to implement all
the questions uh I think there are still
some range of questions that it is not
able to implement as we saw the first
one was not a huge
success but uh I can still give that to
char as it is in Ai and still in a you
know developing mode but still if it can
give you 90% of the output correct it is
a pretty decent and you know amazing
thing to
do
question is shortest subar with some at
least K now let me search for
it
again this question is from heart
category and its success rate is even
low which is 26.1 let's see this
question can be solved by chart
GPT let's have a look at the question
given an integer AR nums and an integer
K return the length of the shortest non
empty sub array of nums with a sum of at
least K so if there is no such sub
return minus
one
so bar is a contagious part of an array
it is also given a description of what
an array is or what sub array is so now
that we
have a new
chat and let
me
change
so here is one way to solve the problem
initialize two pointers uh left and
right both pointing to the first element
of the array initialize a variable so
now this time this it is giving pointers
to solve this question uh you know a
perfect approach in a sequential manner
so that you can also use these pointers
and the Logics it's giving to actually
Implement your own code apart from you
know asking it to generate a
code I can see that it has given the
pointers but not the
code
specific so yes uh it's giving an
implementation of the algorithm in
Python uh again we can see it's not the
Python 3 it's python uh little low
version of python
um switch
to
python then we have to pass
self
so it has generated a code and explained
what all variables and what all
statements have the individual fun
functionality as so we have also asked
it to pass self parameter through its
function and then write the code so
let's see if it aders to it and
generates new code with self
parameter okay so
here is the new code with self paret
passed to the main
function now I do have confidence on
chat GPT till now that it was able to
generate logical and you know pretty
decent solutions for every
question this pass to the class as an
argument when an object is created and
is stored as an instance variable the
shortest subar takes K as an argument
which is the target sum so basically
it's trying trying to explain the code
that what exactly it's doing and what
individual statements have as an
influence on the
code and whatever parameters they are
passing what influence or what position
they hold in the
code uh definitely charity is not just
generating the code uh you know it's
also explaining the logic and approaches
towards it and when it's generating the
code as you can see here they have legit
explained the whole code how it's
actually functioning that's a good way
to you know
put emphasis on you know put a
confidence on the
solution and remove
this
yeah H error okay let
me okay so it's a apologizing it made a
mistake in its previous response the
init method should take two arguments
one for the nums array and
14k so now it's again generating a new
codeing to the syntax error or type
error generated so
let's right or
not
mentioned that here theit method takes
two arguments one for the nums array and
one for the K which was the error
exactly and it's again explaining the
whole code so that one person who
watches code or you know logic could
understand the functionality of
it let's save this Cod Bo can
run
Bo checking for indentation removing
class and
run is one more type
error let's copy it
[Music]
and we mention that we want self
argument to be
passed it is still not able to generate
you know the correct solution twice so
let's see if this time it can work
out issue though with the code
apologize for the confusion it seems
that I misunderstood
the that you are trying to call the
function directly without creating an
instance of the class in that function
outside of the class and simply Call It
by passing the parameters like this okay
the code is definitely generated by
itself def defitely I am not calling any
function uh the code I copied was
actually generated by chart GPD itself
so it's it contradicting its own
pointers
maybe we have copied the question sorry
the code let's paste
it again look for
indentation
and run this
code okay once again it is not able to
you know
pass time error is there now again we
have to copy this error and paste
it
again according to chat gity it was
confused with the context of the
question uh like I said the was anywh
generated by chart GPT so yeah this time
I think chart GPT is trying to
contradict its own
Logics let's see if the current code can
do the miracle of solving this
question
[Music]
class and
run okay so after four attempts of
running the codes generated by CH GPD on
lead code but this particular question
finally now it's able to pass all the
test cases so I can I have a very
contradicting point right now uh not
exactly contradicting more of a skeptism
that okay chat G does generates uh
proper code or logic but it doesn't
considers all the criterias or it also
has a tendency of taking the question in
a wrong
context so I feel that when we as a
human try to solve these questions we
definitely try to implement all the
Logics and if we get it we can actually
get the code in one
go or you know demand of the question
and being AI being the superior version
or you know trying to be the superior
version of human brain and going to the
extents of a human
Brain still faces those issues can be a
you know drawback for chat GPT because
you can see for this specific question
we have faced multiple types of error
and we have seen chity contradicting its
own prior code
so definitely this is something to
consider or you know something to think
about submit this
code and like I said after giving four
attempts it is still not able to pass
all the test cases it is only able to
six pass 61 out of 97 test
cases which is almost 70% of the test
cases 30% of the test cases are still
not passed even though we mentioned all
the constraints we have mentioned the
commment we have mentioned all the
errors that but this particular code can
go through still it was not able to
generate the proper code that could go
through all the test cases so this was a
fail for charity uh at least till now we
have made out this point that Char GPT
is definitely not able to solve every
question
question lit array with same
average
it AR
with
this is from the category of hard
questions and the sucess rate is only
25% uh Let me refresh it and remove this
code now let's have a look at the code
what it demands so you are given an
integer array nums now you should move
each element of nums into one of the two
arrays A and
B and B are non empty and the average of
array a is equal to average of array B
now return true if it is possible to
achieve
that condition is not
justified Al given a note that for an
array uh average array is the sum of all
the elements of array over the length of
array okay so it it is giving the logic
of how to actually you know find out the
average of what average is exactly and
also it has given
a few examples to give you idea how the
code needs to be projected or
implemented paste copy the code and
paste
it
okay it is possible to achieve this by
checking all the possible subsets of the
nums array and comparing the averages of
the subsets so definitely it has given
you the approach uh the way you can
actually think of solving this question
uh however this approach would have a
Time complexity so it's also giving that
this approach can have a Time complexity
of O to the power uh n so again it's
suggesting a different approach a more
efficient approach that will be using
dynamic programming now that can be used
to find the subsets with a specific
average and create a 2d array with the
length of I and J will that will be the
length of the two we have actually given
as input and represents whether or not
it is possible to get a sum of J using
the firsts of the nums aray so
[Music]
so the time complexity of this approach
would be o n s so definitely it's not
given a code uh let me ask for
it not for every question Char GB is
generating a code it is also mentioning
just and approaches that we can actually
use uh definitely again we will have to
mention that what we want from
them as you can see I've mentioned this
time to write a code for it and now it's
generating a new code for
it is also mentioning comments that what
every snippet of the code is actually
for and what it will do like here you
can see it will fill the 2D DP uh DP
stands for dynamic programming this here
it has mentioned initialize the First
Column as true so it is also mentioning
the comments for better idea of you know
understanding the code in a better
way also giving the note that this
implementation assumes that the nums are
is non empty and that the elements of
the nums array are non- negative
integers okay also the above
implementation will return the possible
subset that can be formed by the array
to fulfill the given condition and not
Pion true and false but that's what we
want exactly right uh still okay let us
this approach is in Python so let's copy
this and see this code can run or
not
I can clearly see that again it needs to
pass
self uh
paramor
indentation
give it the heads
up
what I have mentioned what I want
specifically uh sure here is an example
of how you can pass the self parameter
so now the current solution will pass
self
okay there was an A
okay
in and it has generated a new code uh
considering the criteria I just
mentioned that I need self parameter to
be passed through the function can
parip so I have copied it and let's
quickly paste it over
here uh you know pass all the cases and
not wait uh we need to remove
this okay it's done now quickly just run
this
program okay so here is
uh error attribute error solution object
has no attribute okay so let me copy it
and paste it over here and see what chat
GPT has to say about this
error okay the error message solution
object has no
attribute uh split array same average
suggest that there is no method named
with this in the solution class so it is
likely that the test case is trying to
call this method but it does not exist
in your implementation anyway that I
have not mentioned this method this was
given by charb itself so again we can
see the condition that it is
contradicting its own so again it has
generated new response and it says that
it should resolve the issue and the test
case should be able to call this
particular method currectly
so that is something for us to decide
now let us copy this code and see but
now is it able to run or not and pass
all the test cases or
not and click on
run okay
now the new generated response does
works for this particular question and
the runtime is 12 Ms and it do passes
the first two cases mentioned so let us
quickly submit this code and see if the
code is perfectly you know fine to deal
with all the test cases actually fed by
lead
code okay now again we can see one more
situation that this codee is not able to
pass all the test cases even though we
mentioned all the specifications
constraints and we were pretty precise
about the questions and parameters that
we want our code to be done in certain
form but still it is just able to pass
68 test cases out of 111 which is almost
50 to 60% of uh total amount of test
cases so let's move on to the next
question that is find substring with
given hash value so let me quickly
search for this
question find
substring
with
value again it's it's a question from
heart category and the success rate is
22.2% so let's have a look at the
question what it demands so here the
hash of a zero indexed string of length
K given iners P and M is computed using
the following functions now hash with
parameters
SPM uh this is the logic given how we
want our output to be demonstrated in
certain value or how the hash can be
generated the particular formula how you
can get the hash value of your you know
uh
string so the question is you are given
a string and the
integers uh and you have to return the
first substring of that string of length
uh given to you here it's K the test
cases will be generated such that an
answer always exists we are going to
copy this course and mention all the
specifications mentioned here in their
chart GPD console so that it gets all
the
specifications cop the code
and
so I have copied the code and paste it
over here now let's check for
indentation that's fine let's remove
class my
class
and again it faces a type error so let's
move on to the next question again we
saw that CH was not able to solve this
particular question coming back to our
list the next question in the list that
we are going to cover is partition array
into two arrays to minimize some
difference let's quickly search for that
question partition
array
to two
arrays again this question is from heart
category and the success rate is even
more low so let's have a look at the
question first it's partition array into
two arrays to minimize some difference
that is generated as the output
we can see that there are three
constraints so now quickly copy this
question and see if it is able to solve
this question or not first we have to
create a new
chat
copy all the
constraints
let's see what chity has to say for this
particular
question let's ask it to generate a code
this time it has only generated the
logic not exactly Logic the approach
that they are going to follow or anyone
can follow to solve this
question let me ask if it can generate a
code
it's definitely taking longer time to
generate this code okay here is the code
which is possible bython
implementation and
uh okay the code is generated and uh
it's mentioning that the code takes in
an input an array of integer called nums
so basically uh it's explaining that
what it actually it's doing which is
pretty much explained in the question
itself that what exactly it needs to
function like and what will be the
variables and what will be the inputs
and how it needs to be segregated to uh
obtain our Optimum
result
so let's copy
this
and paste it over here again like I said
we can see that it's generating you know
uh again we could see
that pass self
parameter
okay and
then attribute error let's quickly copy
copy
it paste it over
here see what CH GPD has to say about it
okay that you have seen that after
placing the error it's giving that error
message you're seeing suggest that
there's a problem with the function name
in your code so the error message is
indicating that there is no function
called minimum difference within the
solution uh also I have seen that apart
from the function name it doesn't have a
self parameter so let me just write it
down
self
argument
in ABS we let me copy it that will be
better
and write
the new code with
it let me see if it can generate a new
code this
time so yeah it has a GRE sure there is
an example and here's the code so I have
copied
this
and pasted
over see any such huge difference in the
syntax or the logic of the code but yeah
we can definitely think of running now
let's run this
code me copy it and paste it over here
again an error has has prompted out I
don't know how uh
valid code we'll get after projecting
this error over here in chart
GPD so yeah definitely considering the
error message you seeing is indicated
that the function is returning INF which
is not a valid value for the expected
return type
integer so in the base case where I and
J are both zero the value of is set to
float which is positively Infinity
however the expected output is an
integer so this valid this value is not
valid so again considering this change
the chart GB is giving a new code so let
us see how valid this new code
is okay I can see that it has changed
logic over here instead of float INF it
has changed it has uh written a new
syntax a new logic over there now and
also jity gu guarantees that this may
solve the issue of returning INF as the
value let's see how accurate chart GPT
here
is
now we have pasted the
logic uh yeah
as oh sorry I need to remove these two
lines now let's quickly run this
program okay so now as you can see it
could only pass one test case but not
the first two so there's no point of
submitting this code as we can see that
the logic for this code or this code as
a whole is
not well moving on next in the list we
have
is
longest common SAA now let's see
longest
common
subpath so this question also comes from
category of heart questions and the
success rate is 27% now let's see what
this question demands actually now let's
quickly copy this question with all the
constraints and whatever apart from
example is left on the screen we need to
copy it as you can see over here you
cannot just miss out on any
specifications talking about the
constraints
copy and paste now
enter giving the approach to solve this
question which is dynamic programming
approach okay okay we didn't got any
code over here so let's
try that if it can present a
code I have asked to write a code for
this and yes CH GP has definitely agree
to provide me a code for it uh Char is
done with its explanations I'll uh type
it out and wait for the new code which
will contain self as a parameter that
it's this code is pretty similar to the
previous one it's just that it's using
the self argument the function as it was
mentioned by me so let's quickly copy
this
code paste it over here check for the
indent
run this
code I don't should be any okay I spoke
too fast here we have another error
let's see what charp has to say about
this the list index out of range error
is likely occurring on line 10 because
the indices I and J are being properly
bounc checked before being used to
access elements in the path and dprs
okay so we have found a new code let's
quickly copy this code and see if this
code is capable of you
know eliminating the errors we probably
found
C copy and
paste let me check for the
ination done and
run then we got a error over here even
though after providing so many
specifications and criterias and errors
and conditions yet chat gbd is not able
to provide a perfect solution for the
code
uh moving on to the last question of our
list that is going to be uh sum of total
strength of wizards hopefully this
question does some magic for Chad GPT
and prove itself lucky for chat GPT
graph for this video because for now we
can see it's a 50/50 scene uh half of
the question chat GP was able to provide
Solutions with and half of the questions
chat GP couldn't actually figure out
what uh needs to be done even the logic
and approach was correct still the
implementation of the code was not
correct so let me search for
this question some of
total strength of visits again a hard
category question so let's have a look
at the question
first let's quickly copy this question
uh create a new
chat paste it over
here and uh look for constraints now
that we have copied it paste it and
enter is giving an approach how you can
actually uh think of a solution for this
particular question agib has not
generated any code uh let me ask for
it
okay so here's an example again they
have implemented the code in Python now
it is also giving a note that the
approach is valid only if you're allowed
to modify the original aray and also we
are not working on down
over
menion and then write this code so let's
see if it can do it with self
argument okay so yeah there's an example
it's generating the code okay so let's
see what's the update with the
code
okay
thiser
R let's
add
solution and run the
code so there's a runtime error let me
see
why this
error and paste it over
here what Char have to say the error
message solution object has no attribute
mod so just that there is a class name
solution and the code is trying to
access an attribute named mod on an
instance of that class with attribute
doesn't exist we probably uh need to
make more specifications and if it still
doesn't works then it clearly classifies
that charge doesn't takes every point or
classification uh you know in
consideration uh which
ultimately U you know reflects on the
solution the new code is here let me
quickly paste
it okay
let's try running this code let's see if
this
works try running it
again again it has a runtime error was
unable to solve one more question now
that we have tried and tested a huge
spectrum of questions from lead code on
CH GPT we can conclude that though CH
GPD is an amazing tool with the bright
future it's still has its own
limitations and maybe it is not ready to
replace humans or compete with human
brains these questions were picked from
a list of frequently asked questions for
interviews and examinations chat GPT
does have a potential to generate Logics
and approaches for the code in an
effective manner but still its ability
to analyze the question is weak as
compared to humans as we know these
questions are there the success rate
does shows that a proper solution to
exist for these questions but still even
after multiple attempts chat GB was not
able to find the correct answer but we
can also give CH GPD the benefit of
doubt that it's still it in in its
initial phase and still there are a lot
of aspects that need to be worked on so
probably in future CH GP can take an
upper hand over this but for now CH GPD
needs to do a lot of work for these
situations have a look at wide range of
eiml courses by simply learn in
collaboration with top universities
across the globe find the cost Link in
the description box and moving on we'll
start with with our
project and for that first we'll create
a
folder in Python
projects and name it
as
telegram Port using chat
jbd okay and inside this we'll open the
command prompt
and open our ID that is I would be using
the visual studio code and you can use
any ID that you have hands
on and
now we will go back to our chat jpd and
we'll start here but before that uh
let's talk about telegram board so a
telegram board is a program that
interacts with users VI the telegram
messaging app uh the prerequisite is you
you should have a telegram account and
Boards can be used for a wide range of
purposes such as customer support news
delivery and even games and chj so chj
is a large language model trained by
open that is based on gbt 3.5
architecture and J gbt is capable of
generating humanik response to text
based inputs making it a great tool for
building chat
boards and now if we talk about
prerequisites you should have a telegram
account python install on your system
and we need a python telegram board
library that I will show you what to
install and that chat J will tell us
like what to
install so we'll just ask chat
jity to
create telegram
board
using
python okay so it says error we'll just
refresh the page
and ask again create telegram
board using python okay I'll see
what he States so create a telegram
board you need a
telegram Bo talking to the board father
yeah we have to go to the board father I
will show you guys how to do that
install the required libraries next you
need to
install okay and write this
code
okay so in this
script they have started with the start
function
so it will just say us
hello when it would be started
okay so we'll add some more
functionalities
and we will ask uh where to find the
your API token here so I know like we
have to go to the word father but we
will ask chity
also where can we
find the rate
open
so it states that to get to telegram Bo
AP token you need to create a new boat
by talking to the board father on
telegram open telegram and search for
board father okay and send the board
father message that is/ new mod and the
board father will ask you for the name
of the board and it will ask you about
the username and the fifth is the boat
father will then generate a token for
your boat this token is a string of
characters that uniquely identifies your
report on telegram so keep this token
secure and I will also blur it so you
guys won't be able to see it
okay so moving to our
telegram we'll just search board father
here and you can see this is the board
father and we'll just click on
start and they asked the JD asked us to
right SL new new Bo we'll just click on
this and we'll
get so all WR a new board how are we
going to call it please choose a name
for the
board so
right simply
learn underscore
new Bo
okay good let's choose an
username
so
[Music]
simply
learn 1
onecore
Port and it states that that your
username should end in boat so we have
to end it with boat and you could see
the token here and here you can just
access your
board
so we'll get back to our ID
and create a new file and I will name it
as new. py only or you can name it as
board. py anything you want we'll get
back to
our uh chity but before that first we
need to install the library for that you
can go to the command prompt or you
could use the terminal of your
ID that
is uh in Visual Studio code you you
could use the terminal to install the
libraries you could see that the
requirement is already satisfied as this
library is already installed on the
system so moving back library is
installed and now we'll copy this
code and paste it
here and we will just change the
token we'll go back to board
further we'll copy this
token come
back and paste it
here
okay now we will run this and see
whether our board is working or
not so it has successfully executed we
get back to our board father and just
click on simply ONN one one board
so we click on
start and see it says hello I'm your
board so it's working fine so if we
write
hello it won't respond as there are no
functionalities so we will ask jity to
add fun
functionalities please
add some
more
functionalities and
response to the
port let's
see so sure here's an example of how you
can add some more
functionality so the US Port updator
dispatcher
okay Define the help command
Handler
okay
so Chad j has defined three functions
that is Eco and what does eco do it will
just give you the same thing what you
give to the board or what you write to
the board
caps that he has also declared a help
function and in which you can see like
what functionalities does the board have
and the Caps will do it will convert the
message to all caps Eco uh e the message
back to you it will give you the same
message SL start it will start the board
and/ help to get
help and
now unknown uh if there's something you
ask out of these things it will just say
sorry okay I will let you guys
understand this code also but first
we'll see whether it's working or
not so for that we have pasted it here
we'll paste our API token
again so I pasted it here now now uh
first we will close this terminal
and get a new terminal and then run the
program we'll get back to the board F
and this is our boort so we'll just WR
slash
start and it says hello I am your
board
now we'll say
hi to the
bot so okay it's not
responding okay we just close the
terminal and we have pasted
the keys also
okay run it
again now we'll see whether it's working
or not
start
I so the code is not
working just see the word
again okay uh here we don't have any
response to I or l so what we'll do
we'll use the help and to call the help
what we have slel so these are the
commands for what it will
respond so we'll use slash
help okay now you can see that SL start
to start the board that we have done
help and
Eco e the message back to you so we'll
write hi W write back so we'll write SL
equo
High then he has given us the output
that is high so we can write slash
EO how are
you so it has given you back and same we
have slash caps so we'll write slash
caps and we'll write something in small
caps that would
be
greatly
built okay now you can see it has
returned in
caps so you can add some more
functionality to it and before that I
will get you guys understood the
code
so now we'll see what does this code do
so first we have imported the necessary
modules that is the classes from the
python telegram board library that we
will need to create our board so
telegram contains the main board class
while updator command Handler message
Handler and filters are classes that we
use to handle incoming updates and
messages from
telegram okay now these are like uh we
have created an instance of the board
class that is using our telegram board
API token as well as an updat instance
that will continuously fetch new updates
from Telegram and pass them to the
appropriate handlers and we have used
context equal to true that tells the
updator to use the new context based API
introduced in version 12 of the Python
telegram board library and we also used
a dispatcher object that will handle
incoming
updates after that we have created a
start function and passed update and
context so we have defined a function
that will handle the start
command and the update parameter
contains information about the incoming
update from telegram while the context
parameter contains some useful methods
and objects that we can use to interact
with the telegram API in this case we
have used uh context. port. send do uh
sendor message to send a message to the
chat with the idid specified by update.
effective chat.
ID and after that we have created a help
function so we use a multi-line string
to define the help message which
contains a list of available commands
and then we have used the context.
board. sendor message to send the help
message to the
chat and after that we have the e e
function so we use context. arguments to
get the message sent by the user after
the/ Eco command so to use this we have
to use the/ Eco and after that we have
to write the message and then use join
to join the message back together to a
single string we then uh we have use the
context dobard do sendor message to send
the message back to the chat then we
have caps so this function defines that
will handle the Caps command and we have
again used the context to arguments to
get the message sent by the user after
the/ caps command and then the we have
used the upper function to convert the
message to all gaps and then we have
used the context. board do sendor
message to send the message back to the
chat then we have unknown
function that is this function defines
that will handle any command that the
board doesn't recognize so we have used
context Port do send so it will just say
sorry okay so these are the start
Handler help Handler Eco Handler and
caps Handler so these are the
commands and we have the we have added
the ADD handl and to start the board we
have used update do startor
poing so this is how we have created the
board with the help of python and
chity
so we are done with the project you can
add more functionalities also to the
board you can just ask CH jbt to get
more functionalities to play music in
the tegram board or you could just ask
him how to send messages to a particular
user by the boat only and you could
also send media files ask the media
files from the board
and you can train a fully board by the
help of Chad jpd and this is called Chad
jpd scripting so with the help of Jad G
you can just ask him and he will guide
you with all the code and processes you
just have to like make them in a
sequence and use them to full of your
use and before we begin if you love
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel like the tutorial and hit the
Bell button to never miss an update
today
we are going to automate WhatsApp using
python by pyot kit library and with the
help of chat J and before starting I
have a quiz question for you
guys and your question is how much did
mattera that is formerly Facebook spent
to acquire WhatsApp in 2014 and your
options are your first option is do10
million second option is $19 million
third option is 20 ion and the fourth
option is $21 billion please answer in
the comment section below and we'll
update the correct answer in the pin
comment you can pause the video give it
a thought and answer in the comment
section so moving
on now we'll move to create a
project so first we'll create a folder
for a
project and for that we will create data
folder in Python
projects and we name it as automate
WhatsApp using chat
jbd okay and inside this we'll open the
command
prompt and open our
ID that is we want to automate the
whatsep using Python and with the help
of jity we won't write the code on our
own we will ask chat jbd to automate
it we will create the file and name it
as main.
py and now we'll move to chat
jpd
and ask chat jib to write a code to send
messages through WhatsApp using Python
and the pivate kit
Library so we'll give a command send
message through WhatsApp
using Python
and pivot
kit let's see what J responds to us and
we have also created the automate
WhatsApp using python video I will just
Link in the IE button you can check that
out and we'll see what chat jpd tells us
okay country code
message minute yeah it could
work
and first you need to install the pivot
kit
Library by running Pap install pivot kit
in terminal or command prompt okay
replace Target phone number with the
Target phone number you want to send the
message to country code with the country
code of the Target phone number message
with the message you want to send r with
the r in 24hour format and you want to
send message and minute with the minute
you want to send the message okay for
example yeah
okay for it so so we'll copy this
code
and
paste in our ID but before that first
you need to install the pivot kit
library and for that you can go to the
command prompt and write the
command
pip space install
space pivote kit and and press
enter it states that the requirement is
already satisfied as I've already
installed this module and you can
install it by writing the simple command
and you'll get it installed and if you
face any error installing it just
comment down and we would be very happy
to resolve your
queries okay
so as Jad jbd States we'll just enter
the things it want from us so it's
asking the Target phone number and the
country code without plus
sign
okay so here we'll
just WR all the things but uh as you can
see it has also given us an example to
see and work on the code so
here we'll just clear
it I will write the phone number to whom
I want to send the
message so it would
be and I would just blur this number so
so you guys won't be able to see okay
and here we'll just add the country
code and that is without plus
sign
okay so my country code
is you can search it that is I live in
India and the message I want to send to
him is
hello how are
you and
now we'll set
the hour and minute so the current time
is
15:14 so we'll
set 16
okay we'll save
this and run
it so it says that the country code
is
missing so we'll
just copy the error and give it to chat
jbd
as we are taking the health of chat je
in this video so he has given us the
code so we'll just provide the error to
him let's see what it states if it's not
able to resolve this then we will
resolve
it IND country code in the phone number
you're trying to send
okay yes and the country code is 91 to
send the message correctly you need to
make sure
okay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 you
mention the question proved phone number
is this and the country code is 91
okay you need to make sure that country
code is prefix to the phone number like
this 2 3 3 four 5 6 7 8
okay
uh okay we don't have to make it a
string yeah
now we'll run it
again
okay it's a string
only so I will write the phone number
again
this
three
okay now we'll
see what I will
do I will write the country code here
we'll save this and the time is 1517 now
so we just turn it to
1518 save this and run
it
so our code has been executed
successfully that is in 20 seconds
WhatsApp will open and after 15 seconds
message will be delivered so we just
have to see that we have enter the time
as 1518 is the seconds available
for the code to get executed yeah it has
open the
WhatsApp it will take time as my
WhatsApp has loads of chats and
contacts yeah I have to scan
it don't
think it would be able L we have reached
the
1518 we have scanned
it let's see if it will deliver the
message or not else we have to change
the
time
so we just have to wait for 15
seconds let's
see
okay just stop the
terminal and run it
again
41521 so we will save this and run it
again so it states that in 85 seconds
Whata will open and after 15 seconds
message will be
delivered so we'll get fast forwarded
here so we are still
waiting let's see when it will open the
WhatsApp
okay states that the phone number shared
by URL is invalid
okay I'll just check the phone number
[Music]
again okay I entered the wrong phone
number sorry
guys so I will just update the time
again and it would be
15:22 we'll make it fast we'll run
this okay say that the cold time must be
greater than so we'll right 1523 save
it we will make the time is
1527 save it and run
it okay it stes that in 40 seconds
whatso open and after 15 seconds message
will be
delivered it has opened the
WhatsApp and it has started the
chat okay it has return
the and we have send it to hello how are
you that's
good and
now here we have chat GPT okay you can
write here chat. openair.com so here I
will ask to chat GPT what is chat GPT so
I will here write what is
chat
GPT so here you can stop generating if
you want to
okay I will stop generating okay so
charge bit is a conversational
artificial intelligence model developed
by open a it is based on the GPD Genera
pre-rain transform architecture
specifically GPT 3.5 which is at advanc
language model so GPT 3.5 is trained on
a massive amount of Text data to
generate human like response to wide
range of prompts and question you can
ask anything to
chgb
okay
after coming
[Music]
chat
GPT
software
developers are
safe software developer jobs are
safe like me see yes after the
introduction of chat gity and similar
language model software developer still
have important role and their jobs
remain revent while AI models like CH
gbt can generate text and provide
automated response they have limitations
see they have limitations CH gbt have
limitation and cannot replace the skills
and expertise of human software
developers so here is a few reasons why
software developer jobs remain valuable
okay so here are the few reasons so you
can ask anything to char gbt so what we
will do we will create a small small
gaming app okay so here I will
write uh let's make first Tic Tac to
okay so here I will
write give me the
code for
take T
to
game see it will give you the step by
step chb will explain you everything see
this board then player check columns
check diagonals play game everything see
check for the winner play
game everything see to play the game
simply run the python script players
will take turns entering the row column
numbers to make their moves the game
will okay so what I will do okay first I
will ask the steps to make a game tic
tac to
okay give me these steps to make Game
T see first it will uh we will ask for
the steps then we will ask for the
code chity can make your app in 2 three
minutes in Just 2 three minutes small
small app in 2 three minutes okay see
what what is the first step set up the
game board create a data structure to
represent the TIC tcto board this can be
3x3 Grid or nested list with initial
empty values okay for example this then
second is the print the game board write
a function to display the current state
of the board on the screen this will
help players visualize the game and the
third is get player input from the
player to enter their moves accept the
input for the rows and columns where the
players want to place their symbol
X or zero okay or you can change the
value X or zero whatever cross right
okay update the board after receiving
the player input update the game board
with their move make sure the validate
the move and check if the selected
position is empty okay then check for
the winner then check for it is draw
what then alternate
turns okay then repeat 2 to 7 until the
game ends optional add additional
features we will first we will make
tikto uh what you can say a simple tikto
then we will add the additional features
on this okay using chat gbt only okay
so I will
write provide me
The Tick
T
to game
code
what we will do we will uh open the
visual studio and copy it
directly okay see current player is X
then
o see current player o the second player
switch
player okay what we will do we will copy
it from here and we will open the visual
studio that new file I will write here
Tick T
to. P1 okay Enter I will save it so here
I will directly copy the
code where is my code oh it's it comes
in
okay copied this
also copied the whole
thing okay I have to remove this or I
can make it you know
comment yeah so let's try to run it what
terminal
says see enter the row okay
two enter the column
two okay it made like
this okay what I will
do I will ask for the G
right uh provide me
the t t to game with
GUI okay now the Tinker came Tinker is
python Library used for the GUI in
Python
okay okay now uh we'll copy the code and
just paste it it will run okay with GUI
and then we will add the additional
features okay from here now I'm copying
the code now select all replace with
this code like here no error no red sign
so let me play it it will run I guess no
problems
okay what happened see as you can
see we got the ti T to gam okay so see
here x 0 x 0 x player X wins so let me
add the additional features in this so
what we will do we'll go to chat GPT
again we'll ask for the additional
feature see note the code above uses the
message box module from the Tinker for
displaying messages ensure that you have
compatible version to Tinker okay when
you run this code a graphical windows
will appear by 3x3 grip and this uh okay
players can click on the buttons to make
their mooves the game state will
okay okay update you can you know talk
to chity so I I will say
update my code with
some good font and
scoreboard
scoreboard font scoreboard and
color update my GUI code I can
write here is an update see right
certainly here is an updated version of
GUI code with improved font scoreboard
and color if if you get error in this
you can ask to chat gbt
okay anything you are facing issue about
your code whatever it is you can ask
directly to chat
GPT see we created an App in like 2
minutes just in 2
minutes so chat gbt is making our life
easier okay let me copy this
code okay
let's see the changes what what J
does
okay there nothing changed I
guess player X means like this
cross
okay
okay uh I will write here see in this
update code the font style has been
improved with a bold aial font the
buttons have a custom background color
and the overall window and SC have a
different
color oh I didn't feel like
this I didn't feel like
this okay
so
[Music]
change uh
the g style of the
okay it's giving updating the boat see
to change the great of the same you can
modify appearance of the buttons and the
spacing between them here is an updated
gii code with a modified grid
style it's just a little bit of time
taking that's it nothing else it's very
useful JT you can create your app in 2 3
minutes
only
okay continue generating it's a half
code okay code is called
copyed let me select and paste it here
and check
see player X zero player row
zero okay it's little bit different I
guess X okay this one two three box why
these lines then okay who
cares play X okay see the scoreboard is
updated
okay so this is how you can make your
Tic Tac to more
beautiful okay uh let me write
here let me write here I want the black
and white boxes okay or colorful boxes
so
code provide me the code for the
colorful
boxes
okay okay here chb wrote certainly here
is an updated version of the code with
colorful boxes instead of grid
lines
okay so wait waiting for the code update
the
code
see in this updated code each player's
button X and O has a specific color
assigned to it the button colors okay
let me copy the code and paste it
here and run
it see the color is changed here I will
write CX and o x o x o x l x
okay so this is how you can make your
app more beautiful beautiful using
customization you can ask CH GPT
anything color style font or any
function anything you can ask and you
you can make your app more beautiful
okay so now let's move on to the next uh
game which I want a snake game okay
using p game we will make
so here I will write please
provide me the code of
snake
game
using p game
python
okay everyone knows what is his snake
game or first you want to ask the steps
we can ask the steps okay after this I
will ask this
St okay so till then let's make a new
file of
snake game.
py
Okay let me close it so it's a
long code like guess just continue
generating
now you can see the see the food and all
will come
okay you can ask anything like any
question any language question this code
sets up the basic structure for the
Snake Game using p game it includes a
functionality for displaying the snake
controlling its movement detecting
collision with the boundaries and food
and managing the school you can run the
code and play the snake game with P game
window feel free to customize see at the
end what chat GB feel free to customize
and enhance the game according your
preference okay that is what I was
talking
about you can change n number of times
you can ask n number of times for the
code new new code
okay there is one why this error is
coming import pame could not be resolved
P
lens what is this py lens okay okay let
me ask to chat GP
only what
is
vience p is a language server for python
developed by Microsoft which provides
Advanced language features including
code completion type
checking static analysis and code
navigation cap pens is built on the top
of language server okay let me give the
error
itself
copy
message
okay I will write debug
error
vience
okay uh the make sure you have a pame
installed py game is already installed
on my okay install on python environment
open your command prom
terminal and run the following command
okay let me open the command
prom okay then what I have to
write let me copy the code and paste it
here what is
this
okay emergency this this this this
this if py game is not installed you can
reinstall by
running already installed I
guess Ure the Pence is using the correct
python inter verify that pil is confed
to use the same pyth which you have
installed by game you can check the
python interpreter setting in your
code editor or ID which make sure it's
point to correct python where P game is
installed
okay what I will do I will go to
terminal and here I will
write pip
instore P
okay maybe it will be
helpful
okay let me do
this what Char P install by
game okay successfully install new pip
some error of PM I guess okay we'll run
it online no
worries if it won't work in this I will
run it online okay you see the
requirement is already satisfyed this
this this this so what we will do uh we
will
open replate okay
we'll open replate and we'll create the
new
rapple okay then
Python and
create okay this is the same like you
know one of
the ID you can say okay then what I will
I will copy this P
code and paste it here
okay I will make a new file it's name
py okay on that I will copy the code and
I will run
it
okay replate updating the package uh the
p and the buy
game okay it's running the code is
running
okay it's installing P
game okay let me run
now what happened what's the
eror where's the
eror
okay
let okay some hello from pame Community
this
P some game Loop module fil main. P line
okay okay we'll ask to chat
GPT snake game code showing
better
okay
provide me
the snake game code
using python
GI this time from Turtle
okay let's
see because the p games I don't know P
game is installed or my system it's not
working so we will leave
it okay we'll ask from this some good
GUI with some good
GUI see it is the head everything is
there the keyboard bindings from wsd or
you can up down left right the keys you
can use from use the both
okay continue
generating then the functions the pen
the snake body everything is there snake
head is like everything is here what you
want everything is
there see the code utilize the turtle
module to create the basic game with the
snake that moves collect food the the
score
is okay feel free
to let me copy the
code let me copy here
only and
it see this is the
snake Okay this is the food this is the
score or high score okay I will uh run
it
okay see you can customize your snake
your uh food everything see the score
previous time the score was 10 the high
score now it
changes okay the score is 30 now I'm
enjoying the game so this is how you can
customize your you know
game okay let me play the
game okay see this is how you can make
any game or any small small game in 2 2
3 3 minutes
okay so uh go to chat jpd and you want
the you know change the color of the
snake or the food anything you can do
using chat
GPD most of the entry-level jobs in
cyber security field requires you to
trace track and defend against cyber
attacks on a day-to-day basis you are
required to enable systems against all
fraud land activity and prevent any
authorized exess this requires at length
the need to write scripts in various
languages such as plunk Java JavaScript
python SQL PHP Powershell and C amongst
many others as scripts grow in
complexity so does the time to write
them shed GPD on the other hand can
create these complex queries and scripts
within split seconds along with
explaining them this can help save
hundreds of hours of effort for a cyber
security professional this is just one
such use case of how chat GPT is useful
in the field of cyber security although
relatively new the uses of chat GPT in
the field of cyber security is
innumerable from automating daily task
to script writing or endpoint detection
and if you want to know more about how
chat jpd can be used in the field of
cyber security and how I can change the
entire information security landscape
stay tuned with us until the end of this
video for some amazing information
with that being said welcome to yet
another amazing video by simply learn
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
other video from and our first topic is
what is chat jity so chat J is an
advanced AI model chat Port that uses
natural language processing NLP to
understand and respond to user queries
it is based on the GPT 3.5 architecture
and has the ability to learn from
conversations with users making it more
intelligent and efficient over time chat
GPD can be integrated with various
messaging platforms such as slack and
Microsoft teams to provide a seamless
and secure communication experience so
this was about chat
jity now let's understand the uses of
chat GPT in cyber security so uses of
chat GPT for cyber security we'll start
with number one we have threat detection
and response so Chad GPD can be used to
monitor network activity and identify
potential threats by analyzing logs and
data from various sources chat jpd can
identify unusual patterns and Alert
security teams it can also provide
real-time alerts to users enabling them
to take immediate action to protect
their data by using machine learning
algorithms chat J can learn from past
incidents and continuously improve its
ability to detect new and emerging
threats once a threat has been detected
chat GPD can initiate an automated
response or cyber security personal to
take appropriate action this can include
blocking suspicious Network traffic
isolating infected systems or disabling
compromised user accounts by providing
real-time threat detection and response
chat jpd can help organizations to
minimize the impact of cyber breaches
and reduce the risk of data loss or
system downline it can also help to
improve overall security security
posture by identifying vulnerabilities
and recommending proactive measures to
address them and the next we have is
password management one of the most
common ways that cyber criminals gain
access to sensitive information is
through weak passwords CH jpt offers a
solution to this problem by assisting
users in creating strong passwords and
storing them securely with its Advanced
natural language processing capabilities
CH jpd can suggest complex and unique
passwords that are difficult for for
hackers to guess moreover it can save
these passwords in an encrypted format
ensuring that they are protected from
unauthorized access another important
feature of chat jip's password
management tool is the ability to remind
users to change their passwords
regularly this is crucial as it helps
prevent the use of outdated passwords
that can be easily hacked and at number
three we have employ training many cyber
attacks are caused by human error such
as clicking on fishing emails or using
we passwords chat jity can be used to
provide employee training on cyber
security best practices with its ability
to simulate real life scenarios it can
create interactive training modules that
help employees learn how to identify and
respond to cyber attacks for example it
can provide simulation of fishing emails
where employees can learn to identify
the warning signs and avoid clicking on
malicious links or downloading harmful
attachments next up we have Incident
Management
Incident Management is an essential part
of cyber security as it involves the
process of identifying assessing and
responding to security incidents that
threaten an organization's information
or technology Assets in today's digital
age cyber attacks have become
increasingly common and sophisticated
making Incident Management even more
critical one of the ways chat GPD can
help organizations with Incident
Management is providing stepbystep
instructions on how to contain the the
attack mitigate the damage and restore
normal operations when a security
incident occurs time is of the essence
and organizations need to act fast to
minimize the impact of the attack J GPT
can help by providing real-time guidance
on how to respond to incident
effectively and the next we have is
compliance management many Industries
are subject to Regulatory Compliance
requirements such as HIPAA and PCI DSS
these requirements ensured that
organizations adhere to certain
standards and regulations in order to
protect the privacy and security of
sensitive information failure to comply
with these regulations can result in
Hefty fines and reputational damage J G
can play a significant role in helping
organizations ensure compliance with
these regulations with its ability to
process large amounts of data in real
time it can provide alerts and guidance
on best practices and compliance reports
this can help organizations identify
areas where they may be falling short of
compliance requirements and take
corrective measures to address
them and now we'll move to Hands-On
demonstration but before moving let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers by taking our courses so
just hear to them hi I'm Phillip I'm 61
years old and last year I upskill with
simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the it sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors I worked with many
companies before as a a security analyst
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with infosis
as a cyber security consultant happened
after I took the course but first and
foremost I've been a learner be a
learner first and now first we'll see
what is chat GPT you could just write
chat GPT on web on any browser and this
is the website where you will cling and
this is the website for
charting so you could see the samples
here and what the user has asked is this
code is not looking like I expect how do
I fix it so he has pasted the or input
the command to chat jpt and pasted his
code and chat
J has answered that it's difficult to
say what's wrong with the code without
more
context so this is how chat jpd responds
and when you just click on here try chat
jpd you will have the window here so
this is the chat GPT window and here
we'll start with some Hands-On lab
demonstration for our cyber security
like how J gbt can help us in cyber
security field so we'll start with the
basic questions and we'll see what he
answers us he or she answers or what J
answers us so we'll start with the basic
question
explain the mitm
tech
okay uh for big
so we'll see what it
responds certainly a man in the middle
attack is a type of Cyber attack where
an attacker secretly intercepts and
possibly Alters the communication
between two parties without their
knowledge the attacker positions
themselves between the two parties sence
the term man in the middle okay he has
given us a very good
definition and here's a simple
explanation of
okay and I want to ask
him can you
explain this to a
OR7 year old
kit so we'll see how chat GPD can
mitigate or just try to understand this
Con up to a
7-year-old so he has answered us that's
sure imagine you and your friend have a
secret way to send messages to each
other using a special code you both
trust and only you two can understand
the messages but one day someone sneaky
sneaky comes in between you and your
friend without you knowing they secretly
listen to your messages and even change
them without you realizing it it's like
they're hiding and watching your
conversation the sneaky person can
pretend to be you when talking to a
friend can pretend to be you
okay so he has taken the good
example and they can also PR to be your
friend when talking to you so you might
think you talking to a friend but
actually you talking to a sneaky person
the sneaky can do bad things like
stealing your SE changing to take your
spy who can listen to everything you say
and even change what you he has taken a
very good example to get this concept
clear to a 7year old kid really
impressive so we will ask him some more
questions and we'll ask the last basic
question that would
be what is
SQL injection and after that we could
ask him some code
Snippets what is SQL injection
and
provide a real
life sample to understand the concept so
you have to to write these prompts and
you have to be very specific and you can
follow up with your prompts also when J
jbd answers you you can follow up him
and ask him more about it as I have done
here first I have asked him explain the
IMM attack for beginners and he has
given me the definition that is
technically and now I have asked him can
you explain this to seven-year-old kid
and he has answered me with a very good
example similarly you can do the
follow-ups for any PRS so now I'm asking
Chad j what is SQL injection and provide
a real life example to understand it for
a
bner and let's see what Chad gy answers
us so SQL injection is a type of Cyber
attack when attch experts oril in a
website so he is giving us the
technical
definitions okay impressive is's also
telling us here how the attack might
work
okay and he has also suggested us to
protect against SQL injections
developers need to implement proper
security measures so this is the attack
that is on the database that you can
read here or if you know that is very
good we are just checking how chat GPD
responds or give answers we are not
implementing
or like we will asking the code Snippets
but we will not be able to implement in
this video we are just we are here to
just check out what chat gbt provides us
for cyber security
field
so you can
see he has given us a very good response
and moving on now we will ask
him uh to generate a CTF challenge that
contains an SQL injection
let's
see what it
answers so you could see that J is
responding to us that is show here an
example of a CTF that is capture the
flag challenge that involves and SQL
injection
vulnerability challenge title product
search Okay challenge description
welcome to the product search challenge
you have access to an online store
search feature you can find products by
typing keywords your task is to exploit
and SQL injection vulnerability to
retrieve hidden information okay and he
has challenge code Reve the admin
password from the database and challenge
instructions with the challenge website
find the search box and start searching
the go to
expect okay so we could see the example
solution let's assume the website search
functionality is vulnerable vulnerable
to SQL injection you can try and putting
the following in the search box okay
explanation the injected SQ statement
quy to always evaluate to True semicolon
have ter the original query and the Comm
out when you execute the search the
modified query might look like okay so
it is like what response he has given is
is very nearby you can have the followup
commands if you want something from him
so we are just checking what it provides
so he has given a very impressive
answer like truly speaking a very
impressive answer so moving on we'll ask
him some other questions
so okay I will ask him how can I
[Music]
scan and I can scan for SM
vulnerabilities with n map so I will ask
him that
only and that is with n
map so let's
see so to scan for SMB you can utilize
nmap scripting engine and a specific SMB
script here's how you can do it okay
here has given us the steps
also so you could see how CH jity guides
you to every process you
need so first we have to install the N
map and you guys if you are willing to
implement this you can implement this it
he has given you all the
steps I won't be implementing as I'm
just quaring the chat jpd how he can
answer the
questions so install n map and I then
identify Target and then we have to run
this n map with SM SMB script
okay okay that's good and then review
the
results it's very impressive how jity
answers to these questions and now I
want him to give me a code example to
check user input for no SQL
injection
so show me a code
example check user
input and that would be for no SQL
injection see certainly when it comes to
preventing no SQL injection the key is
to properly
sanitize and validate user input before
using it in database quer is okay that's
good and the specific approach may very
depending on the programming language
and database system you're it okay but
here's a general code example in
JavaScript using nodejs and be
okay
okay and function
input and okay uh this thing the chat
jpt has done is very good he has
explained the whole code like if a
beginner wants to learn and wants to
have some queries resoled he can just
see like what the function are doing and
what this code really means so in this
example we have sanitized input function
that receive us an input and applies an
necessary sanitization or validation
logic to prevent no SQL
injection it's very good so you could
just copy and use the code and if it
gives you error you can just have
followup questions
that we'll just ask him this code code
might have some
error can you
Rectify so let's see what J answers us
apologies for any confusion cost here's
an updated code example that addresses
potential errors and clarifies the
usage and you could see that he has
given
us a little
I don't think he
is okay he has changed something and he
has provided us updated
code okay yeah there are
some changes I've seen okay so in this
updated code the DB connection is
closed this is the change here and
username and perform save query function
now includes a try catch okay like if
there is any exception or something so
he has updated the code if you guys Cote
any error you could just paste the error
here and ask him to rectify it so chity
is very good for cyber security I
think and moving on we'll have some more
like queries for chity and we'll see how
it will
respond so we'll write a
query m is
okay we can ask him to filter IP using
spun spun
okay so okay WR
a regular
expression and plunk to filter
I let's
see so to filter IP addresses using
regular expression and spun you can use
the re okay yeah you have to use
that that matches IP before
addresses okay this is good and you
would see that he has explained what the
script means so Rex command used for
extracting field based on regular
Expressions field equal to row specify
that we want to apply the regular
expression to the row field which
contains the row Lo data that is very
good so CH dep is giving us answers like
a pro
so we could also ask him a spun query uh
to detect command and control Bing
activity using subdomain DNS
request so for that we'll write write a
plunk
query to
detect command
and
control cing
activity and that would be using
subdomain DNS
requests okay let's see so to detect
command and control that is C2 beoning
activity using subdomain DNS since PL
you can
query okay very good so J J has answered
this also and he has also shown us
here's how the query works and the query
will display the domains and he has
stated what it will show as the output
so he has also told you that is make
sure to replace your index your Source
type and threshold with the appropriate
values for the environment that's very
good so you could use this and Implement
many things in cice
security I'm very impressed with that so
we will ask him one or two more queries
and I also want to check I will give him
a code and let's see if he can find the
errors in that or not as we have seen on
the chat jity page okay
okay so what we can ask him now is like
we can ask him the script to get
malicious IPS from s and block it on my
firewall
okay so we ask him generate the
script to get malicious
IPS that is from
C
and block
it on my
firewall okay so to generate a script
that redes malicious IPS from s that is
security information and management
system and blocks them on your fir you
will need to integrate your with your
firewall good and use the appropriate
apis or commands by your fir good here's
an example of a high level script that
demonstrates the
concept Okay so just
see okay he has provided us a good
script and please note that this is a
generic example and the actual
implementation will depend on your
specifics s and firewall system yeah
this is correct and you'll need to
replace yeah you have to replace and
ensure that you understand add to
documentation and guidelines provided by
SCM and Fir wance for integrating and
blocking IPS
good so you could see like how he is
helping
us and
now I will ask him a last command and
yeah and after that we will ask him to
get extracted some erors from a
particular code and that code would be
simple
only so we can ask
him a Shell Code that would execute
cmd.exe
okay generate Shell
Code that
executes cmd.exe
okay I'm sorry but I can't assist with
generating Shell Code that executes
arbitrary commands or facilitates any
malicious activities my purpose is to
provide helpful and responsible
information to users okay so you can
trick him to give you these but I think
he has been functioned to not provide
these so no
issue uh we'll ask him to generate a
macro see if he responds to
that generator
macro that exit
CES CMD
doc let's
see okay so it won't give us this answer
I apologize but I won't be able to
generate a macro that executes CMD do
exe or facilitates any potential harmful
activities my purpose is to provide
helpful and responsible information to
users if you have any other malicious
questions or need assistance with a
different topic feel free to ask and I
will be glad to assist you
okay guys so I think it won't respond to
this and now I will ask him to
rectify some errors and gives the
perfect code and I will provide him a
code so I'll ask
himy
and a working code
this Cod
snippet okay so let's
see certainly there are a couple of
issues in the Pro code snippet and
here's the rectified
version okay I know
like oh yeah I didn't pass data I miss
the brackets also
here and let's see what he has given us
so the
line modifi to yeah he has passed the
data columns and the is connected
to
okay I didn't know that was the error
also the rectified code now properly
reads the file data calculates the md5
hash and returns it please ensure to
provide the correct file path and file
path okay that's very good so I think
this is for it
and we have tested the chat GPT how he
can help in like who wants to pursue in
cyber security so we can get the answers
we can write the codes and in upcoming
videos we can just make a project using
this uh we could have a password
generator and I know the CH jpt is a
tool which will help us in every field
and in cyber security field it is
helping us a lot and yeah to some
questions it doesn't
answer like that is for the security
purpose or the script shouldn't be used
for malicious activities so that's why
the software has been programmed for
that have a look at wide range of e IML
courses by simply learn in collaboration
with top universities across the globe
find the course Link in the description
box AI art and chat GPD can be used to
create unique and creative have designed
by combining the power of artificial
intelligence and human input with AI art
you can generate visually stunning
Graphics patterns and images while chat
jbd can be used to generate text content
and provide suggestions for website
layouts and design element it's
important to keep in mind that while AI
can help to generate ideas and create
stunning visuals I'm going to show you
exactly how you can generate these
yourself websites are going to be built
with AI art as well as tools like chat
GPD in future so in this video I'm going
to explain the whole process and we are
going to have it write the entire
Website Layout for us all the content
the hero section and feature section and
much more this means that we can build
an entire website from the ground up
without writing a single line of code
and this will be a pretty damn Cod All
right we will start with the mid journey
in Google search we will
write M
Journey this is an AI tool that allows
you to create the AI art that we are now
seeing all over the web to go to this
you just go to the mid journey.com and
join the beta it's easy to get started
because all you really have to do is
join the Discord when you do this it
will open up the Discord Community which
you can accept the terms and condition
and start creating your own AI Arts
let's do this
now here I have got the mid Journey
server and I'm going to head over to one
of the new newcomer room here and and
where everyone is creating different
types of AI art the first thing we need
to do is are to do a forward slash and
type in an imagine give us prompt
for we can uh request the AI any type of
art we are after here I'm going to type
uh in a bu ful
website
for
shoe then I'm going to pass in dash
dash V4 which means uh the version four
of the mid journey of air tool finally
I'm going to pass it in style stylize
I'll do dash dash stylize it's basically
how random we want to B in uh it's
between 0 to th000 and I'm just going to
set it to about 500 which is average so
I will do the enter it will take a
little bit of time here this will start
working in the background it's going to
generate a low Fidelity version of the
website and the design for this art and
this low Fidelity version will be
iteratively updated to be higher in
resolution these four examples then can
be picked from and then we can upscale
them as well as uh let's have a look at
what kind of results we get now one
thing uh to notice here is that we do
get a bit of a loading percentage bar
and this is how long it takes for the
actual AI to generate the image uh
usually takes between 1 to 2 minutes but
it will essentially refresh and ping you
once it's complete so here is it is
complete and here are the four versions
that we got which are not too bad uh not
that great either they are bit uh yeah I
suppose it's looking a funny in a way so
this is where we can start being more
creative with our prompts so what I mean
that uh is by giving more context as to
what we want to do so here is a prompt
that we have created what I'm going to
do is to pass it in the imagine once
more and I paste this prompt in this and
I'm going to give some more context I'm
going to pass it to the word you are i o
choose UI
ux UI ux website this basically means
that it's more or less focused on having
good UI and good at ux and being more
like a website rather than just a
creative shoe or a design and it's
important to give these context clues to
the AI if you want better outputs
different types of uh context clues you
can provide is to find a kind of style
that you want uh for for example um how
you want the design to look and feel
whether you wanted to represent a
certain brand or much much more like
these are just simple examples but let's
take a look at the kind of results we
will get just from making these small
little changes to the design here here
you can already see uh a wait a minute
look it's a little bit more interesting
we have a bit of our sliders and what
looks more like a Nike shoes and also
have uh uh what looks like a menu at the
top and and I really like this uh design
uh that we have here on the bottom and
here it is because it does look very
much like a website that we have got a
bit for a hero section or a hero set
section and what's not so from here we
can select the version one uh so from
here uh we can can select uh the version
1 2 3 uh 4 to upscale and I'm going to
upscale version three where which is u3
and this will give us a higher
resolution version of this one
particular design that we can uh that we
can start to take uh to the market or
even you can use to build this again uh
will take a little bit of time it's
going to process this and uh to do and
you can upscale in data and let's run
this in the background so that you can
see uh a wait a minute this again will
take a little bit time to process it's
going to process this and do an UNSC or
upscale in beta and let's run this in
the background so that you can guys see
what's the look so here's the final
result and this is looking uh pretty and
we have got a nice design here for a
shoe uh we have got a bit of a hero
section and we also have what looks uh
like a two call to action
and we got some option here to at the
very bottom and as well as at the top we
have got the colors and that essentially
are looking like these shoes colors
being used as a part of the website
design so not too shy uh let's select uh
the another one let's see
for yeah uh but I think we can do a
little bit more um in terms of
customization the design for this
website and I'm going to show you how
you can do this I'm going to copy over
this uh prompt once and for this prompt
this time I'm going to pass a couple of
extra things so let me just uh maximize
this we are going to type um as I have
uh pasted that URL over here so I'm
going to pass uh in the context clues of
like uh clues of Nike because Nike made
obviously website showes so
also uh so we'll write it
here my
key right
here
repeat and I also I want it to be
red
blue
green
and or uh maybe uh
yellow and I suppose uh we want to uh
else uh running
person would be
interesting
sorry
person uh it would be interesting to see
how that gets designed uh and I think
that this should be enough let's
actually improve the styling here uh 1
minute let's change the
styling
let's let's have it
750 uh to make it a little bit more
creative and here are the results I
don't have a running person but I do
have a website that has definitely
started using the colors that I
recommended uh with joury AI art systems
to use so these website designs look way
more creative than we had previously
still we have this slider design these
website designs look way more creative
than we had previously we still have
this slider design here at the bottom
section where we can pick pick out
different shoes but even these shoes
look damn cool I can see that the Nike
logo on these and these are actually
ones that I would probably buy if I saw
in the Nike store but generally uh these
also are website because we have got the
menus here at the top of the right uh we
got the text so generally speaking uh
these are pretty interesting interesting
designs so now I have another option
here called version 1 2 3 three four
what this does is actually allow you to
pick uh more Generations uh based on a
actual image from these images or these
designs now from these design I actually
like the trail three and four I think it
is most I think four cuz uh it teals and
red or it's a bit yellow or blue so I'm
going to select the version um four and
that's going to create uh four more
version based on the specific version
for us let's take a look at the what
those that we got and here we have got
our
results uh where we have more examples
of that all of these looks very similar
I think the only difference here is uh
Blue Line a red line it's seems to be
shift and change as well as a hero
section and and you would normally have
this menu at the top right and something
these shoes here are a little bit
inverted but generally speaking this is
the kind of variations you can
expect now let's take a look at another
way we can generate Our Generations for
website now you can do is just uh jump
into any website and select any image so
first we will go to an app and website
and you can uh select any image that you
would like and I will actually go
here and I'm going to pull in this image
of this shoe and but I do like the
design Aesthetics uh here we are going
to here and then we can copy the URL
from here but this time what I'm going
to do is type the
imagine imagine
then I'm going to pass uh in the URL
what we have copy uh we will paste it
here again I'm going to
write we did it before we'll copy
this paste it over
here so what's going to happen here it's
uh it's going to have a look at this
image that we have defined in in terms
of the URL it's going to use this as a
reference point then it's uh going to
take a look at the prompt we have bon
which is the shoe promt using the colors
and it's going to try to
design a website that has a similar
athetics to that image which is really
cool let's see the result we get back
looks like uh that's ready uh let's take
a look at this so here you can see that
the design is
Statics uh wait a minute static uh that
is uh similar to the page seen in this
one so this is more bubbly and colorful
image and now I represented very much so
in this design
Aesthetics uh we have these four
elements here at the bottom and if you
have a look at the design originally uh
we had four elements here so you can see
that it's pulling in these design
Aesthetics to create a design based on
that and this is where you can really
start using the air art repeat using the
air tool to your own benefits trying to
combine different styles customizing
them and creating new and independent
and unique ones from there so in this
four I'm really like uh uh the version
of fourth one or the second one is uh
pretty so uh what I'm thinking of doing
is an upscale on this so we are going to
upscale uh V2 and we are going to wait
for that uh 1 minute is uh use chat GPD
to write out the most of the content for
me and then I would I could take this to
to a client to immediately start sailing
so let's see the upscale version happen
if we take a uh closer look we will see
that it has all the main elements for a
website including a logo area uh a menu
area a nice hero uh image as well as a
title tagline Button as well the feature
section uh so what I'm going to do is to
save this image to my computer I'm going
to save it and then custom
it a little bit but before we do that uh
we are going to head over to GPD here
we're going to prepare the outline for
the website using some AI tools so here
I'm going to ask tpd to give me the
broad prod
outline for a website for
shoes including hero title
tagline call to action button and
section for features and details about
the shoe so let's see what tajber will
comes back with um it's pretty quick uh
it's got a Title Here call to action
button features and detail section and
it's not really telling me what these
are
these are where we might need to be a
bit more specific as to what we wanted
to do it's given me uh it's giving me
like broad outline of the website on
what it needs so please I will
write please
provide
t for each one of these that I can
copy
paste
straight to the
website um hero title is here tagline
call to action
buttons
features
okay and the
details okay detail specification is
there okay reviews and
rating
okay so I think I have got enough hairs
to go by to Simply copy paste in the
website so let's start beginning to
design this I have opened this design up
in the Photoshop and I'm going to
actually just crop it into the main
element over here and I really want to
capture this
image and I will crop it and I will
clear out the the rest and we can design
each aspects or each part of this
design bit by
bit I will save it over
here it's time to build our website so
I'm going to head over to editor
X and I'm going to build this uh a
website in this and I have login already
and then I will create to a new site and
here I will takeen to a web uh dashboard
and I'm going to start by copy copy
paste all the elements from chat gbd as
well as mid Journey straight and the
first thing and I want to jump back into
the chat GPD here and copy over our hero
text so I will just take it
first
and I'm going to Tad add title and I'm
going to paste it over
here and then I'm also going to grab the
tag line but before I will make it sure
to keep it over
here but before
that I will first I will put one image
over
here I will change the
image as I have already uh downloaded
the
image
let's upload that
image we'll open it let's wait to get
uploaded
yeah it's uploaded and now we will
update
it let's make it big in
size okay so we
will we will change the size but first I
will remove this I will change the size
for this I will make it little
small next I will add the icon
for uh for the company of the shoes that
we I'm going to make a website for I
will add this and I will update
it make it
small and this will be the task bar
but
make the size uh small a bit and
we'll insert one more
[Music]
picture and it will be the logo of the
company that we are going to put over
here we will minimize it we can resize
it can
keep keep the logo over
here now next uh then I'm going also
going to grab the tag line over here so
I'll
the I'll pick this
tag I will add the
text comes up over
here okay I'll make it small in
size
and we will paste
[Music]
on
and finally Let's uh grab a call to
action which says
sh and create a button button for that
so so here we have all the workings of
what we uh at least what we would need
at least so for for the
content let's resize this
first now we will add uh we need to add
the image itself so instead of just
having a browser stock images or
anything like that we actually had our
images either done inside of the
photoshops that we have done before as
from the mid Journey as well as so I'm
going to just
drag the
image and I'm going to change the
image and it should be here I've already
download it no I have to upload it I
have a collections of
some shoes uh let's
see and I will just install when I'll
upload this
picture
it will take a bit of time let's wait
for a
while and once it's uploaded we
will we will update
it and
add
let's keep it like
this or we
can
so uh we we change our content place
from that to make it a fix in a place so
here we can change this
also a pretty
well
okay so basically have this text uh
happening a little bit more
here we have seen how we can resize it
from this scroll bar
and so now let's add one more uh picture
over here to make it look more better
let's take a picture from
here change the
image upload
from
[Music]
computer
form
oh we will upload it again
sorry
and we'll update
it resize
it
let's turn it
on
Let's uh make a taskar for the top top
most of the uh screen we will have a
homepage so we will write a text over
here that will be
make it small a bit in
size we'll add another text
it it will show about
us it will show about us section so
we'll write it over
here this
small
let's make same
size speak more
small alow let's make it
more alow
okay uh the next next session will be
services
and the last one is context one
section
one more option is
there uh that is a start button like uh
we are keeping the start button over
here so we will we are keeping this here
so let it be
here
yeah
so next uh what I'm going to do I'm
going to
select add uh section and I'm going to
just have a blank section
um here I'm going to do first I will add
a picture first as a
background let's do it I will add one
picture let's see I have downloaded or
not I download it wait a minute uh Let
It Be
[Music]
upload I will update
it
that would be a whole for a whole
page
so let's add the pictures now for
another
shoes
change the
picture I'm going to be open this
iput
this okay I'll
update to
add
keep the pictures over here like
similarly we will upload three pictures
over
here
after this let keep it
here keep this
here
we are going to add another title over
we are making it a
bit
it
we will change the font for this let's
make
this after this I we will start editing
the features of the shoes
let's go to chat
GV
let's take this
first
paragraph make it
small
me make it
B
we will add another paragraph over
here
similarly we will make it for this also
and last we will
add a contact
us
last we will add a contact uh section
over here
again
so this is the final
output of chat GPD or how we use chat
GPD and AI art for our UI and designed
to create a website or a web page or the
land page for the shows
during our childhood we have heard the
fictional stories of robots taking over
various household courses making the
lives of humans easy peasy but if you're
not aware then these fictional stories
are turning into reality though not in
the form of physical robots but yes in
the form of computer programs and apps
with with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
Technologies confused let me introduce
to you to chat GPT a pre-trained model
that interacts with user in a
conversational way chat GPT is founded
by open Ai and the model is based on
supervised and reinforcement learning so
are you excited to know more about chat
GPT chat GPT has various application in
various domains in this video we are
going to see the application of chat GPT
in the SEO domain also we are going to
discuss how chat GPT will play an
important role in search engine
optimization so here is a question for
you chat GPT is based on which of the
following GPT models created by open aai
option one chat GPT 1 option two chat
gpt2 option three chat gpt3 and option
four none of the above let us know your
answer in the comment section below and
if your answer is correct you will get a
hard from Simply learn we know that SEO
rankings depends on various factors like
on page optimization off- page
optimization and more while using chat
GPT we will understand how chat GPT
helps in various Su ranking parameters
and reduces the manual work so without
any further delay let's begin so to
begin with let's open chat
GPT
we need to go to new chat which is
already open
here let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SE optimized uh blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog so before
that let's choose what kind of blog we
want to create I really love traveling
so let's try to create a travel blog so
for the travel blog we will find some
good
keywords
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of
them
okay so here we got around seven of the
results so let's try to get something
for
Japan so just me good keywords to create
a
blog on
Japan okay so what I understand from
this is we are just getting few of the
random
keywords okay so it is
it is showing that these keywords cover
a range of topics related to Japanese
culture history food and
more uh out of these I guess we can
start with the places here are few
places like Mount
Fiji Tokyo and everything so let's try
to create a
blog on top 10 places to visit in
Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in
Japan
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in
Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword
recommendations and it is also
suggesting that by using these keywords
our content will be more dis
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank for for for for search
rankings
write me a Blog on top
places to
visit in
Japan so the idea is we will try to
write a blog and after which we will try
to uh optimize the blog with respect to
the keyword top 10 places to visit in
Japan and we will also uh see whether
all the practices can be easily
applicable or not using chat
GPT so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with a introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of
it also like uh uh chat jpt provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the the blog or article or
anything you want uh to several number
of words like if this Blog has 2,000 or
5,000 words you can just ask chat GPD to
reduce it to 2,000 or th000 words
also so here you can see that before
when we search there were only one
liners about these destinations these
places in Japan and now we are getting a
about all the 10
places
definitely we have targeted this blog
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more keywords to increase its
reach
suggest few more
relevant keywords for my
block okay so we are getting some more
keywords
here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this
blog
as a good title helps the user to click
on your content and it uh increases the
possibility to get more and more
traffic so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which is somewhat similar
to what we are
expecting at the best
suitable title in my
blog
okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss okay so here we got title for a
Blog but here we can see there is a
slight limitation that it is suggesting
the title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my
blog for the
keyword top 10
places to visit in Japan top 10 places
to visit in
Japan with an
optimized
title
for
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to add the title in the
blog
optimize blog for
the
keyword top 10 places to visit
and
okay so here it is showing the relevant
suggestions so maybe there is a
slight ambiguity in the query that's why
it's not representing us the correct
results
we are going to optimize our blog using
all these
factors
visit in
Japan again the these are the
suggestions let's try to implement these
one by
one add headings H1
H2 in the above
blog so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and
H2 and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in
H2
H1 and H2 tags are some of the practices
in the on page optimization which uh
helps the search engine boards to
understand that this is something
important really important uh for the
page and they pick up these hints for uh
getting your uh page
rank so yes it is implemented
e
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2
implementations let's try to get some
interlinks for this blog interlinks have
their own importance as interlinking
your blog with other pages of your
website or your blogging Pages this will
help you to gain the traffic from other
pages to your blog and uh uh putting the
traffic from your blog to other pages of
your
website also it helps the search engine
boards to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure
also
so suggest me
few
interlinks for the above
blog
so yes definitely these are the relevant
and uh expected links we are getting so
if you have any of these uh blog pages
in your uh website or if you have
created any of these blogs earlier do
Interlink
it
which of the
above can I use in my blog so definitely
there are number of suggestions but if
you want to choose one how can you pick
the one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for
this okay
so it is not only suggesting that we can
use all of the above but it is also
showing the significance of
interlinking okay moving
ahead so till now we have optimized our
block for keyword top 10 places we have
tried to to get some of the keywords
relevant to the uh top 10 places to
visit in Japan we have added headings
and we have tried to get some of the
good Interlink suggestions to add
interlinks in our blogs which are some
of the good practices of the on page
optimizations so next moving ahead in
another onpage optimization technique is
let's try to get a cover image for this
blog so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
Blog
Page okay so it is showing uh some of
the suggestions related to to the
diversity of the country panormic view
of Tokyo Skyline the beautiful image of
Kyoto traditional Temple Mount Fuji
hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park so we will try to pick one and uh
see if we are getting any image
idea let's take for Mount
Fuji
suggest me the image idea for
Mount so let's see we have seen in
generic for all now let's see for uh
image suggestion specific to M
Fuji okay definitely it is showing a
number of suggestions for the specific
Mount fu
image so if you are looking to create
another block for Mount fui then these
ideas are easy to take
up optimize
the
mount fui image for my
blog here are some tips to optimize the
image for Mount Fuji for my blog which
are they're showing that the image
should be high
resolution then a clear
subject
definitely if you have a large image a
large file size it really gets difficult
to load and the page load speed will
increase so if you have a large file
size the image should be
compressed without reducing its quality
image
quality we should have descriptive file
names and ALT
tags
okay so let's try to get a very good
file name and all tag also we will try
to implement a good caption because
adding a caption is very good in the uh
when considered as a
user
so get
me
good
image title
and ALT tag
for Mount Fugi in
image so there is importance for L Tac
as search engines are Bots uh they won't
able to identify the image directly so
alxs helps the search engines to
understand what the image is
about so yes it is showing not one but
number of suggestions for all the Mount
Fuji recommendations which we got
earlier
so we will try to choose one and get a
caption for
it write a
good
caption
for for the
image
Scenic
Fugi Five Lakes
Region so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions
here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to 40
words reduce the above caption
to not even 40 let's do it in 20 20
words
okay this one is
better now let's try to get the image if
there is
any
choose the
mount fug image for my
blog choose image it should not I
repeat choose the perfect
illustration
for Mount
Fuji image for
my
blog so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us the suggestion what we can
choose again this is the limitation that
it is not showing us any of the image we
will try to put it in another way to get
an
image if it really works we can get
it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat
GPT we can only get the recommendations
to choose the image and yes it is
showing some suggestions of un unsplash
pixels or Shuttle stock to to download
the image so we can uh really navigate
to these websites and download some of
the required image for our blog so we we
have uh completed here with the image
optimizations let's try to get some
video ideas because again having a video
is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your
website or your blog
page suggest me suggest video you ideas
for the
above
blog okay so if we are getting few of
the video
ideas
which of the above idea is best match
for my blog let's try to extract anyone
from the
above okay so it is completely
dependent on the user's Choice what a
user wants so here I'll
choose
for again we will continue with Mount
Fuji
only
provide video optimization
optimization
ideas video
optimizations
for Mount Fugi video for above
blog
okay so it is showing us some of the
suggestions which uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our
choice so let's take the thumbnail
suggestions in our next query uh if it
can suggest us a mount Fusion
uh thumbnail uh image suggestion uh and
the video tag suggestion
right suggest
me
good thumbnail idea for Mount
FG
video thumbnails have the Major Impact
for any videos it is the only thing
uh I
repeat
thumbnails thumbnails are one of the
important factors which encourages the
user to click on your video and watch
the complete
video so definitely having a good
thumbnail will help your content to
rank so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our
blog so we are done with the thumbnail
ideas after which we will get we will
try to get video tags so for getting
video tags let's get for all of
them find
me video
tags
for the all of
above
thumbnail
suggestions tags are important to help
the user to get your videos in the
search
list like if someone uh uh types Mount
Fuji in the search box and if the Mount
Fuji keyword is or a tag is added to
your video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly user may click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important um onpage optimization
practices now let's try to get backlinks
which is one of the most famous off-page
optimization
technique
above
block okay so it is
showing some of the link
suggestions
so basically backlinks are the
links which points from another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website so getting backlink uh is
one of the trust factors in the search
engine size that your content is really
unique and more of more users wants to
read it and share it with another uh
users so the search engines by by by
these search engines understand that
your content is really good and it is
worth of ranking so definitely getting a
good backlink from a very good authority
websites is uh fruitful for your
content so let's try to
get which
pages on web are
suitable to get back links for my
blog so here we are getting some of the
ideas or suggestions that which Pages we
can choose to get a backlink so here is
industry specific websites so if you are
writing a travel blog there should be a
travel trip ad uh Trip Advisor like
websites uh which are showing more of
the trip oriented or bookings related
oriented for travel or uh
destinations there are few of the
directories okay government websites
which are the tourism websites in our
case right
now blogging websites and social media
platforms which can be relevant to the
current scenario which we are using here
so let's check how can we get
backlinks from
the above
of
recommendations for my
blog okay guest
posting broken link
building okay these are some of the
backlink building methods which we are
getting so that we can find one and get
one of the black uh I
repeat so these are some of the backlink
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a backlink
for our
blog
let's choose a specific platform and try
to get the
recommendations or the ideas to get back
links for the from the blogging
site so we can implement the ideas and
it it may be possible to get
backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks for our blog let's try
to add the catchy metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only uh data
which is U which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to let the user
know that what the blog is exactly about
so it is considered to be a good
practice to have the targeted keyword in
the title as well as in the description
so let's try to get
one
s
create
SEO
optimize meta title and
meta description for my
blog so we are getting some suggestions
here top 10 places to visit in Japan
discover the best place to visit in
Japan top 10 destinations definitely we
have your top 10
destinations see also we are getting
some of the notes
that it is good to have meta title less
than 60 characters so if if it is more
than 60 character you may get the dot
dot part and the title will not be
clearly visible in the search result
page
so let's try to again optimize The Meta
title and meta description for top 10
places to visit in
Japan description for the key
word top 10
places
to visit in
Japan
okay so we can use any of the one the
one we have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our
content so one of the technical SEO
factor which we are going to see here is
getting the URL
recommendation uh URLs are the important
factor uh it helps the search engine
boards to understand about the page as
the URL is the first thing search
engines may be visiting to come to your
page so uh it is a good practice to have
the keyword in your url
rather than having some of the abrupt
characters like x a r at the rate these
kind of stuffs in the link so let's
create the URL
suggestions suggest
me SEO
optimized URL for the above
block
see so here we are getting top 10 places
to visit in Japan which is definitely
our blog and as a keyword we are using
it to optimize our content and it is
placed in the URL so this URL is
completely
correct
also these kind of suggestions are very
good for the newbies in the uh search
engine domain as they will definitely
understand why and what we are doing to
optimize our
pages so next moving ahead with some of
the non-technical aspects which may
impact which may definitely impact to
bring the traffic so let's try to get
some of the sharing suggestions
like which
platforms should
I I
repeat which sharing
options should I add in
my
block
so out of the mentioned uh sharing
buttons we can add any of them adding at
least three to four sharing buttons is
considered to be really good out of
which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common WhatsApp Shares are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common so you can choose any of these to
add it in your
blogs
dust
commenting
on my blog
impact
on traffic source so here we are taking
the suggestion that will this help or
not again this is again linked to the
back links that if we are adding the
commment section someone else may ask
for a backing for their web and this is
again uh going in symbiotic way like if
they are asking for a a backlink for
from your blog you can even ask from
them so this is a way of or a part of a
communication to get a back links as
well can you find
the
duplicate
content in above blog so duplicate
content is a concept where search
engines you you must be aware that
search engines are really in love with
the unique content so having a duplicate
content may
really uh affect your uh uh web
visibility and it is possible that your
page may get dead after a
time so plagarism is not at all allowed
uh when you're creating a content
it is not suggested in any
case Okay so it is not uh able to uh CHP
is not able to identify the duplicate
content however uh it is suggesting us
some of the tools like copy scape or
sideliner to understand if the content
we are creating for our blog is
duplicate or
not and H let's get some suggestions how
to
make content
unique just in case if someone is not
aware to create a unique
content we can get some of the tips
here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SE
that is 44 Pages 44 pages
are really not are not likely to get
searched
because I
repeat let's try to see another aspect
of technical
Su uh try to find some 44 pages on the
website
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find 44
Pages uh it is not possible for the chat
GPT to get one but we can use uh some of
the tools suggested like uh screaming
frog or Google search console where we
get the detailed report of the broken
links or 44 pages that is the dead pages
of our
website so let's wrap up from the uh
view of the technical SEO
perspective let's consider one of the
scenario that we have published this
blog and how can we promote this blog to
reach more of the relevant audience
so okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer uh add it as a guest
post and Link back to this this blog
email marketing yes it is the most
trending technique to reach more of the
audiences P advertising
commenting content
syndication yes medium and Linkedin are
the very famous platforms for this
online communities
so you can you can definitely uh try to
be the member of the online communities
and forums where you can just put up the
link and the members of your Niche may
definitely visit your content and share
it with others
also so yes we we have seen that uh
search for as as a perspective of search
engine optimization chat GPT is uh
helpful really really really helpful to
create the in content Creation in
optimizations and many of the other
things have a look at whyde range of IML
courses by simply learn in collaboration
with top universities across the globe
find the cost Link in the description
box today in an era of mobile devices
robots and social media content creation
is the most effective inbound marketing
strategy nearly 40% of marketers say
content marketing is essential to their
marketing strategy and 81% say their
company views content as a business
strategy original and highquality
content can help your company stand out
and attract new customers and help your
business grow on that note welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel today we
are here with a fantastic video on chat
GPD for Content creation which will help
you create some compelling content on
your desired topics but before let us
understand what is chat GPT here now
content creation can be of any type such
as blogs podcast videos graphics and so
on but how do you create high quality
content with a few minutes it not be
worried when we have chat GPT now even
though there are numerous AI writing
tools for Content creation chat GPT
stands out from the crowd due to its
faster response rate ease of use
increased productivity support for
multiple languages and other benefits
now let's try to understand what exactly
charge is and how to create content from
it now generally chat GPT is an open AI
trained and developed model that works
conversationally chat GPT is capable of
systematically resolving all bugs while
providing detailed explanation for each
step it takes so in simple words chpt is
a tool that creates content for any
query chat GPT stands out among all the
other achievements of open AI so let us
now move ahead and understand how does
chat GPT work now chat GPT uses deep
learning techniques to generate humanik
text which is based on a machine
learning model derived from the large
language model class now it is trained
on a massive Text data sets from the
internet and learns patterns and
relationship between words and phrases
it responds to a question by selecting
the next word based on the context and
then repeats the process until a stop
condition is fulfilled so as a result
chat GPD can logically respond to your
queries and commands so let's see how to
create content in chat GPT now as we
already discussed content creation can
be of any type so for instance let's
take blog a Blog is an online general or
a website where a writer or a group of
writers share their views on an
individual subject now there are variety
of categories for writing a Blog so
let's pick one for chat GPD here so as
you can see we have navigated into chat
GPD and let us now ask a simple question
about food blogging now lately food
blogs are the most popular blogs that
everyone wants to write about about so
let's find out what chat GPT has to say
about it now you can give any question
to chat GPT and it will answer so I'm
just uh writing a question here saying
how to start a foot blogging
carrier so as you can see it is
generating the answer for us uh wait for
it to
end well as you can see it is saying
that starting a foot block can be a fun
and rewarding way to share your love of
food with others so it is showing us
some steps to get started in food
blogging career it is saying choose an
nishe choose a name and domain choose a
blogging platform create your blog
create high quality content and so on so
in this way CH GPT will automatically
generate the response for you based on
the questions that you are giving input
to it next we will see another question
on lifestyle blogs now with the world on
social media everyone wants to read more
about lifestyle especially of a famous
or a popular uh entity what habits they
adapt and what to let go of Etc so let's
explore this segment in chat GPT as well
and see what it will show the answer so
let's uh give the question as how to
start
lifestyle blogging in
India so it is giving the answer for us
guys so it is saying that starting a
lifestyle blog in India can be a great
way to share your experiences and
knowledge with others who share similar
interest so here are some steps to help
you get started again it is giving some
uh important points for us you order to
start your lifestyle blogging career
like choose your nishe choose a name and
domain choosing a blogging platform
create your blog create high quality
content and so on chat GPT has been
helping in various Fields like customer
support virtual assistant education
content generation language translation
research and information retrival
personal productivity entertainment and
more now talking about content creation
then chat GPT can prove a valuable tool
in idea generation writing enhancement
research and fact checking SEO
optimization and social media content
chat GPT can assist you with content SEO
or search engine optimization in
following ways
number one is keyword research chat GPT
can help you to identify the relevant
keywords and key phrases that are
commonly used in your industry or
required for your topic by discussing
your content with chat GPT you can
uncover valuable keywords to optimize
your content for search engines so let's
find some keywords to create content on
shoes we will create a blog on shoes so
let's add query to chat
GPT so here we got few suggestions we
can pick any of them if needed you can
check these keywords in any keyword
research tool to check their search
volumes if you require so let's choose
this keyword let's write a blog using
chat GPT in 500 words on this
keyword
next we have is content
optimization chat GPT can provide
insights on how to optimize content for
better search engine rankings it can
suggest where to include keywords
naturally within your content recommends
heading structure and advice on
appropriate keyword density so to the
above created blog let's find the
optimization
so here we saw the number of
optimizations suggested by chat GP for
our content the next we have is meta
tags and descriptions Chad GPT can help
you to generate compiling metat tags and
descriptions that accurately represent
your content these elements are
important for search engines to
understand the topic of your content and
display relevant information in search
results so let's ask chat gbd to write a
creative meta descriptions meta title
and meta tags for this
blog
if needed we can rephrase these metad
descriptions and titles as per our
requirement by providing another query
the next trick to master SEO content
with chat GPT is content length and
quality chat GPT can guide you on the
ideal length of your content based on
the search engine algorithms and user
preferences it can help you to ensure
that your content is of high quality
engaging and informative which can
positive L impact on your SEO ranking so
let's understand what can be the ideal
length of this shoe
blog as we have already written a 500
Words length of blog let's change it to
another one suggested by chat
GPD
interlinking and site structure chat GPT
can provide suggestions on how to
structure your content and incorporate
interlinks effectively interlinking
helps search engines to navigate your
website and understand the relationship
between different pages boosting your
overall SEO so let's get few of the link
recommendations for our blogs on
shoes
the next one we have is user intent and
readability chat GPT can assist in
understanding user intent and optimizing
your content accordingly by discussing
potential user queries and preferences
you can create content that aligns with
what users are looking for enhancing its
relevance and readability so let's check
out if the readability of the given blog
or blog created by chat GPT is good or
not
you can also test some other content
with chat GPD to check whether its
readability is good or not while chat
GPT can provide a valuable guidance it's
important to remember that is a complex
field and requires a holistic approach
it's advisable to combine chat GPT
suggestions with best practices industry
knowledge and ongoing SEO strategies to
achieve optimal results small
introduction to search engine
optimization the goal of SEO is to make
a website more visible and bring in
income from natural traffic it entails
crafting excellent content for a
specific audience and optimizing a
website for search Eng
online marketers employ AI to accomplish
various tasks such as keyword research
content optimization and Link building
more quickly businesses can boost their
ranks and increase their revenue by
using AI in SEO strategies additionally
by automating routine processes it can
save time and resources also if you want
to master the field of search engine
optimization and digital marketing
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing is clearly the right
choice for you this postgraduate program
in collaboration with perdu will help
you master search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search psychology keyword
research Advanced ad features and move
not only these skills but you will also
learn a number of tools like SE ranking
hoot Google ads Keyword Planner and much
more so hurry up and find the course
Link in the description box for more
details hear it from a Learners who have
experienced massive succcess in digital
marketing through this course I moved to
United States 4 years ago to live with
my family I have a background in social
media but doing the same what's
difficult here more so because my
English is not that good last year I
decided to pursue the professional
certification program in digital
marketing from Pur University offered by
simple learn I I like that the course
provides such as flexible schedu for
attending the live classes it came with
a recorded feature with a blessing for
working professionals like me helped me
make significant progress and I already
using the skills to sell my products
online I believe that I have come one
step closer to living my dream life in
America so let's talk about SEO
developments with Chad GPT and Google
bar undoubtedly the influence AI is
anticipated to have on search engines
have been highlighted by the recent
launches of Google's B and chat GPT
assisted B although these recent
advancements pose a sever danger they
also present opportunities for digital
marketers to seize in the world full of
SEO things change all the time and SS
are never St the page that a search
engine displays as a result of a user
search query is known as the search
engine result page or S this is why it's
important to be able to change with the
times and benefit from new technological
developments digital marketers
increasingly use AI for keyword research
heading ideas and content optimizations
this is so they can concentrate on the
jobs that need human interaction small
sites May produce original SEO friendly
material much more quickly with Chad GP
than they could without it for instance
however it's vital to remember that this
is only a portion of the process it can
assist you with creating and providing
meta descriptions and titles keyword
research heading recommendations for
pages and posts article ideation and
composing copy so let's talk about the
role of AI in keyword research every
business utilizes AI to increase
productivity automate labor intensive
operations and make data driven choices
numerous Industries including finance
and banking e-commerce retail media
gaming research space exploration
Transportation automative medicine
manufacturing security and uses it in
ious ways the Google AdWords Keyword
Planner and the Google Trends tool are
two of the most widely used free
artificial intelligence keyword research
tools you may find keywords with a lot
of search volume and little competition
using these tools another crucial aspect
to take into account when choosing
keywords for your website is intent this
is so because users frequently have a
purpose while searching for goods and
services although it might be
challenging to ensure your website
appears high on search engine visual
pages especially with Google's algorithm
adjustments SEO companies and marketers
must constantly check their websites to
make sure that their websites are not
falling in the servs they can use AI to
automatically analyze search traffic
statistics and website content to spot
potential issues before their arise they
can then address these problems and
offer consistent organic rankings this
is a game changer for SEO companies and
marketers who realize on manual SEO
efforts to get traffic to their websites
but the main question is will chat GPT
or Google B take over SE the answer is
clearly a big no why chat Bots like chat
GPT and Bart cannot replace SEO they can
help generate content for your website
or video but SEO involves more than just
content creation it includes tasks like
keyword research link building and
Technical SEO where you'll need an SEO
expert because chatbot can decide how to
build links and which links will get you
more organic traffic as SEO is
constantly changing due to search engine
algorithms search engines like Google
and Bing regularly update their
algorithms making SEO a dynamic field
SEO requires human judgment and decision
making the end of discussion because
determining which keywords to Target and
which links to build require expertise
and human decision making a chat bot
can't do it in fact the real power of
search engine optimizations lies not in
their mechanical abilities but in their
creativity and ability to understand
what people are searching for and why
that's something that AI Technologies
may never be able to replicate and it's
what makes human SEO experts such a
valuable asset so while it's true that
AI Technologies may eventually be able
to take over some of the aspects of SEO
there's still plenty of rooms for human
experts to thrive whether you are a
seasoned SEO professional or just
starting out there's still a place for
you in this exciting and ever evolving
field let's keep an eye on on the
developments in AI technology and see
how it can augment and enhance our
skills rather than replacing them
entirely who knows with the power of AI
and human expertise combined the future
of SEO may be even brighter than we can
imagine so with that we have come to the
end of this discussion although everyone
can have different opinions on this but
I hope you guys must have got an idea
about why these AI tools are not a
threat to a SE if you still have any
questions or doubts let us know in the
comment section below and team of
experts will help you at the ear chat
GPD is truly a fascinating technology
changing how we interact with language
it's the result of years of research and
development by open AI who have trained
the model on a massive amount of Text
data to create a machine that can easily
understand and generate humanlike text
imagine you are a digital marketer
looking to make a big impact on your
next campaign Chad GPT can help you do
that Chad GPT uses natural language
processing or NLP which can assist you
in creating compelling humanik copy for
your website social media and email
marketing it can even generate product
descriptions and add copy that is
engaging and optimized for search
engines using chat GPT will save time
and increase your productivity allowing
you to focus on other important aspects
of your campaign and with its ability to
generate multiple text variations you
can test and Define your messaging to
find the perfect tone and language that
resonates with your target audience get
ready to revolutionize your digital
marketing game with the help of this
video you will gain a deeper
understanding of how chat GPT can
supercharge your efforts as a content
creator or digital marketer say goodbye
to mundane tasks and hello to a 10-fold
boost in productivity let's dive in ever
since open a launched CH GP it has been
making waves in every field be it
academic marketing engineering or
content writing so here's a little
trivia for you who are the investors in
openi the company behind the development
of J jpd and your options are option a
alen musk and Sam Altman option b Jeff
Bezos and SAA option C Mark Zuckerberg
and Larry Page option D zma and
masayoshi Son drop your answer in the
comment section below okay then let's
get started there are many uses of CH
GPT in digital marketing its main USB is
smart human sounding content writing we
can command it to write content related
to marketing first on our agenda is an
ad copy there are various ways to go
about it but we must understand that no
matter how much content sounds like
humans it is still a piece of content
written by an AI so you have to give
detailed and precise queries to get the
best results let's start by giving it a
basic command like write an add
copy
as you can see it gave us random ad
content let's give this query more
content like write an add copy for
simply learn digital marketing Master
[Music]
course now as you can see it gave us a
more precise ad copy we can also ask to
make it longer or shorter let's give it
a next query can you make it
[Music]
longer and VOA it gave us a long version
of that same content now let's try to
convert it into email newsletters V
digital marketers often send emails to
promote our products and services so
let's give it a query as can you convert
it to email
newsletters as you can see it has
generated an email with a subject line
and body that is enticing and engaging
to read we can also utilize chat G to
correct grammar or change the tone of
the content for example let's enter a
new query what is
[Music]
Facebook it has given us a general
overview of Facebook now let's ask it to
rephrase it more engagingly and in a
digital marketing context we can give
queries like can you make it more
engaging and relatable with digital
marketing
[Music]
as you can see it has completely
replaced it and it is more interesting
to read it as well J GPT can also help
with keyword research so let's try it we
will give a query as suggest more Search
keywords for a digital marketing C
side
[Music]
and voila it has completed a work we
used to spend 10 to 15 minutes in a few
seconds you can request to write blogs
as well let's give it a query to search
for some keywords for the blog suggest
keywords to write a blog on digital
marketing it gave us some keyword you
can ask it to reduce these topics based
on search volume to get maximum results
let's ask it to narrow it down to five
topics based on keywords
volume here we have some suggestions
let's pick a topic content writing and
ask it to write an article on content
[Music]
writing
here we have a article for the blog
let's use chat GPT to se optimize it
let's first first requested to give us
meta title and meta
[Music]
description here we have meta title and
meta description for this article we can
even request it to give us an SEO
optimized URL
link we can also request it to write the
SC optimized version of this article
just give it a command as also can you
as you optimize this article to improve
Google search
[Music]
results
here we have fully SE optimized article
with meta title and meta description
with a SE optimized URL chat GPD can
also be used to train your customer
service chat boards but we can discuss
the process in some other video chat gbt
is well versed with its content writing
capabilities it can even help you write
product marketing campaigns let's try it
with this query the query is write a
product marketing campaign for simply
learn digital marketing
courses well J jpt has done it again
this campaign looks interesting and it
will be able to generate more leads for
simply Lars courses Chad JP can also be
used to write scripts for YouTube videos
let's give it a query s write a script
for 5 minute YouTube video promoting
simply learn and its digital marketing
[Music]
courses
as you can see it gave us full script
along with few suggestions for video
editor on where to put logos and clips
to make the video more engaging if
you're a content creator and you don't
know how to approach other content
creators for a collaborative video then
chat GP can help you with that it can
help you writing collaboration emails as
well did you know Microsoft is planning
to invest $10 million in Chad gbt
developer even silicon Valley's biggest
conglomerates have begun to take note of
chat GPT versatility and practicality
people have started earning money
through chat GP and some even predict
the Revolutionary AI chatboard will
replace Google search but what makes
chat gbt so resourceful what chat GPT is
and how it works and at the end we will
discuss some of the ways that CH GPT is
being used in the real world the
potential implications of this
technology from chat boards to language
translation chat gbt has many
application that make it easier for
businesses and individuals to interact
with technology so hello everyone I am M
and welcome to Simply learn make sure
you are subscribe to our Channel and hit
that Bell icon to stay updated with the
latest technological Trends before we
move on to the demo part let's discuss
what chat gbt is and proceed further for
the same so what is chat gbt chat gbt is
a conversational language model created
by open AI it is a form of generative
pre-rain transform gbt model which was
Stained on a data set of conversational
prompts such as diog Snippets and chat
logs the model is capable of generating
humanik responses to text input so now
let's understand how chat GPT actually
works this model is pre-trained on a
large Text data set and then fine tune
on a smaller data set is specific to the
everyday task when the model receives
input from a user it uses the pattern it
learned during fine tuning to generate a
response let's take another example the
model can generate an appropriate
response even if the input is not a
complete question or a sentence after
seeing what is chat gbt and how it works
now moving forward let's see how we can
use chat GPT in our day-to-day
life so this is a Google search here we
will write
chat.
open.com chat
will take
time this is the chat window UI of the
chat gbt so our first use case is chat
gbt can explain complex subjects okay so
first we will ask like
what is neuros
signs
it will take
time it's taking time to load because
many of the users are
using it started Neuroscience is the
scientific study of the nervous system
which includes the brain it will write
all about the Neuroscience you can ask
anything any subject okay like hard to
hard easy any or even you can stop
generating too if you want
to okay so this this is how you can ask
like any question to the any complex
question to chat gity okay uh we'll ask
one more like what is
quantum it's loading I don't know why
it's taking time because of net issue or
I don't know why take time and it will
come
quantum computer is a field of computer
sence that uses properties of quantum
mechanics to perform operations on data
like this
okay who state zero or one and all the
quantum Computing
knowledge okay so this is how you can
ask anything like any about any complex
subject to the charity okay so with with
chat our Second Use case is we can write
code using chat GPT okay we can write so
here I will give give me a
machine
learning
program
for
prediction okay press
enter okay so so here let's start it
here is a simple Python program that
uses cited Line library this this this
and
this this is how you can take write a
code any code if you ask anything like
sorting like add two
numers or
palindrome anything you can anything you
can ask from chgb it will give you a
code proper
code
very right please note that this is a
simple example of short prediction is a
complex task and this example is not
enough to make a good prediction it
would need a lot more data feature
engineering and model tuning to make
accurate prediction okay
so let me give another Java
implementations
implementation of the what bubble
algorithm okay let me ask
this yeah it started like here is a Java
implementation of the bubble sort
algorithm so give you proper runable
algorithm okay like bubble
sort give you full
you can ask any type of code any type of
like apis
anything it will explain to this
implementation uses nested Loop to
compare adjacent element in the are and
swpe them if they are in the wrong order
okay and then after the outer loop
completes the array will be sorted in
ascending order our third use cases we
can debug the code okay so for that what
I will I will take this one
code okay I will take this code and here
I will write debug the code and I will
paste it here and what I will do I will
instead of
temp here I will like I will
write
okay I will write 2p okay so now what it
will do Char will do it will D work see
the error in the code is in the this
line okay a r j TMP it should be temp
you can see here it is temp so from jity
you can debug the
error okay you can have the conversation
with the pull the chat
like if you have any question you can
directly write what's wrong in the above
question and like this okay like you
have an extra p in this variable name
which is causing a compile error this is
because temp is the variable that you
declared earlier to store the value of
current element whereas stamp is not a
variable that has been declared here you
can see the stamp is declared here so
that is why the error is causing the
code not to run once you fix the issue
okay like sort the arrange sending order
using the bu sort algorith okay so using
chat GPD you can easily debug your
errors the code and it is very helpful
on your project building okay so fourth
use case is you can create custom
marketing plans or strategy okay I'm
repeating again you can create custom
marketing plans or strategy like how so
here I will write
how
should
promote
videos on social
media okay
present it will give you proper plan how
you can promote your YouTube videos on
your social media
okay I will chat with this okay I will
ask some
question views engagement everyone knows
there are few strategies you can use see
first second and more like more to come
like share your video on personal social
media account this include your Facebook
Twitter Instagram and other accounts
things like that join relevant
communities and groups through use
social media ads platform like Facebook
Ina Instagram and Twitter TT collaborate
with influencer it is also true create a
hashtag for your videos use YouTube
video building sharing
features it will give you all the
marketing plans it can create marketing
plans any type of
plans see remember your video should be
engaging informating and should be
provide value to our audience it is
something like that now I will ask one
question to chat gbt okay so I will ask
what
if
make
only travel videos
okay what if I will make only okay
travel
videos so how should
I
capture the
audience you can ask any type of
question okay relevant to this question
or this answer you
got okay now let's
see it will give you everything if you
are making travel videos there are like
few strategies you can use to capture
and engage your audience like this okay
show the unique interesting aspect of
the destination you visit people are
often drawn to new and unique experience
like share your personal experience and
insights it will give you a proper plan
like how you can increase your audience
engage your audience
okay collaborate with other travel
bloggers is true engage with Audience by
responding to comments messages
true remember your video should be
visually appealing and provide valuable
information to your audience it is also
important to be authentic and true to
yourself like this okay so this is how
you can like using chat gity how you can
create your marketing plans or your
something like that okay our fifth use
case is we can generate articles and
blogs using chat gbd okay so let me ask
write an
article
machine
learning but sh is also machine learning
kind of machine learning on machine
learning in 500
Words
presenter it will write only exactly
like 500 Words it will give you only 500
words like machine learning is rapidly
growing field that is transforming the
way we live and work it is a branch of
artificial intelligence blah
blah basic idea of machine learning is
that computers can learn from data
without being explicitly programmed like
supervis learning is the most common
type of the machine learning yes
true you can see here there are three
main types of machine learning
supervised learning and supervis and
enforement it's true it will tell about
it will write a
proper article in in only 500 world not
more than
that
okay machine learning has a potential
application very interesting in
healthcare machine learning good patient
data and more accurate diagnosis like
this I wrote 500
Words it will give you exactly 500 Words
your conclusion in conclusion machine
learning is rapidly growing field that
has the potential to personalize many
Industries it allows computers to learn
from the data without being
exp this is 500 Words of article okay
you going ask write article videos
descriptions blogs
any kind of content writing you can
see okay so let's do one more question
in the same so I will write give me a
FY
on to
write okay skip for my
YouTube
channel YouTube channel YouTube
shorts
videos video on cyber
security
okay here is a short script for funny
YouTube video on cyber
security like
narrator welcome to the world where
every click could be your last exactly
ly so something like
that one always use strong password like
password one 123 or
4 the tip number two never click on
suspicious link unless it's linked to be
to free
pizza see this is how you can create
your funny how you can generate your
content from chat gbt using chat gbt
okay thanks for watching stay safe out
there please note that the script is
just for fun exactly we know and not
mean to be taken seriously it's
important to take cyber security
seriously and follow best practices to
protect your personal and professional
data okay so this is how you can write
your make your content so easily like by
writing the title of the content our
sixth use case is you can even Summarize
the book or article using ch
like how I will write here
Summarize the
book Del
travel
is novel written by Jonathan Swift in
this the book tells the story of liel g
a ship surgeon who become shipw it will
light only it will summarize all about G
travel yeah in part one this
happened washes up on the island of Lort
yeah
exactly two this happen and part three
this
happen this is how you can summarize any
book any related to like educational
novel fiction any type of book or
article and
blogs okay whatever you want to
summarize page will run the book is
being commentary on the Society of sft
one
time okay so this is how you can
Summarize the book believer St
our seventh use Cas is we can ask
interview question too using CH so here
I can ask how to
answer
what
is
your
weakness okay
so when answering the question it is the
best to be honest but also to frame your
answer in a positive way yeah exactly
for example you could say something like
I have a tendency to be perfectionate
and sometimes struggle with delegating
task however I've been working on this
learning like this you can ask any
question any interview type question
okay related to HR or technical anything
you can
ask so let's see
how
to
answer
the
viewer uh like where do you see
yourself in next 5
years
take when answering this question it's
good idea to be align your answer with
the company's goals and values yeah
exactly for example you could say
something like in 5 years I can see
myself gr within the company and taking
more responsibility exactly so this is
how you can ask any type of HR questions
you are facing off okay
so our next use case is our e use case
is we can develop apps using chat
gbt okay yes we can develop apps using
chat gbt like I
want to
write an
Android app
that shows
me
each
stock
prices as
a
list
from uh let's see
Yahoo
API
okay or how can I
do like this so it will write up prop
Android app code for
you a new Android project or it will
give you a proper idea how you can make
a you know
app all the
steps from starting to the
last
use a view holder to hold the reference
of the views for each item in the list
okay use asynchronous task to fetch all
the step from starting to the
end this is a brief overview of the
steps and you will need to take a build
Android app okay okay so this is how you
can like ask anything to
create app okay using any language
flirter Java python any language okay I
repeat our ninth use case is we can
create our exercise plan diet plan using
jgb okay so I will write my weight is 25
okay let's
take 25
kg and I want to lose
create
create 7
Days Seven
Days plan
for and
plan for
it okay it will get see here is the day
exercise and the diet plan that can help
you lose day one exercise 30 minute risk
walk or jog di start your day with a
healthy breakfast of oatmeal berries
like this it will create exactly seven
days okay this is our ninth use case we
can make any type of plant diet plant
food plan exercise plan or anything like
marketing strategy anything you want
timable of focusing something anything
you can
make and according to you yourself you
can rearrange them okay it will be very
easy and it is very
timesaving okay it will create seven
days plan day six xise 60 minutes 10
session like
this this you want to
lose heyers avocado toast with post
deck it's important to note that this is
just a plan Simple
Plan so our 10th use case is last use
case if you can ask any genine Knowledge
Questions to chat jit like
okay who
invented
firsted by German Goldsmith
yeah
okay you can cross question to CH answer
okay this is the all the use case of
chat GPT like it can debug the code
audit the code like explain complex
subject create custom marketing plan or
strategy diet plan exercise plan you can
generate your content like article blogs
you can Summarize the book and the
Articles or interview question
preparation or developing apps
coding you can easily do with the chat
GPT okay I hope you understand how to
use chat GPT and what is chat GPT okay
and the use cases of chat GPT and where
you can use in day-to-day life if you're
looking for ways to generate passive
income without putting in too much
effort thanks to the advancement in
artificial intelligence and chat boards
it's now possible to earn money using
these Technologies in this video we'll
explore some of the effective ways to
generate passive income with JJ JJ is
known for being the world's smartest
generative Ai and is changing the game
when it comes to making money online
with this revolutionary free tool you
can earn with little skill and no
Capital required there is an exciting
New Era of artificial intelligence and
now is the perfect time to get involved
and take advantage of this opportunity
people are using CH J for YouTube
blogging freelancing and for many other
ways to make money so let's dive in and
discover how to make money using CH jity
and generate various passive incomes
there are variety of ways that you can
make money using CH je we'll discuss few
of them in this video and we'll start
with first we'll see the list of all the
ideas from which you can make money the
first is get business ideas from chat je
second is freelancing third is build a
software fourth is boost your affiliate
marketing with Chad je email expertise
fifth is leverage Chad je for blogging
success the next is unlock the potential
of chat J for affiliate marketing and
then we have utilize chat J for ebook
writing and self-publishing this is the
main thing what people are doing to make
money using chity and then we have
utilized ch to enhance your YouTube
channel and then we have writing lyrics
for music so starting them one by one
we'll start with get business ideas from
chj by getting to know your interest
talent and obstacles Chad jity can
generate tailored business Concepts that
align with your expectations let's Dive
Right In and ask J J for some business
ideas for a computer science engineer
who has experience in digital marketing
and sales CH J and ask him that I am a
computer science graduate or computer
science
engineer with experience in sales and
marketing and what side
hustle should I
start
generate around
$1,000 generate $1,000
follow income that would be per
day and that would be with minimum
investment I
want n is not
work day with minimum
investment and I can also tell him how
many hours I can dedicate so I can
dedicate 8 to 10 hours okay 8 to 10
hours to this side
as PR
Center so you could see that chat jpt
replies us that as a computer science
engineer with expans and sales and
marketing the several side of sales to
generate $1,000 income per day and he
has stated the first one is e-commerce
then affiliate marketing digital
products you can create and sell digital
products such as ebooks okay freelancing
social media management and YouTube
channel you can start your YouTube
channel so these are the ideas that you
can get from chat jib and but these
ideas tailored to user skills and
interest that I have put in now it's
time to take these ideas and discuss
them further with chat jity to
conceptualize a plan so consider
important factors like alternatively you
can begin by stating generate a new
business idea for digital products you
can write that and he will guide you how
you can start it or you could just
write can you
elaborate the
business
idea of
digital
products I
want to start the
side hustle with
this and then you press enter and you
can see that it has
started the process for the business
idea certainly starting a side hle
centered around digital products can be
lucrative and fulfilling Venture
identify your expertise man your areas
of knowledge skill and passion and then
he has stated choose your product format
create valuable content set up an an
online platform Market your products
build an audience optimize for
conversions provide excellent customer
support so these are the parts he has
stated and moreover you can elaborate
those parts also you can just ask chat
so how can I identify my expertise and
he will guide you with that so you can
go deep down and explore any business
idea so this was the first method
through which you can generate income
from CH GPD and moving on the next would
be freelancing so take your freelancing
game to the next level with ch GPD this
stateof the-art AI tool is enabling
professionals to an extra income and
produce top quality content that BS
clients companies are even offering
incentives for those who utilize this
technology to create polished well
researched work so here are some
freelance services that you can offer
using chat jpd starting with you can
write blog or website content using chat
jpd for others you can translate any
language with J jpt you can craft
compelling headlines and calls to action
with j jpt and moreover you can do
create social media content for posts or
marketing for other people or any
advertising agency you can write
captivating short stories using chj and
you can conduct # research using chat
jity that is you can find what is
trending and offer your services to
other people and gain money so the these
are the ways which you could freelance
and have some money in your pockets uh
you could just write a command that
would be write a blog
post and you could write on any topic
that would be write a blog post on US
economy so you could use this AI tool as
your means like what the what your
client required you can use for that and
write the perfect without blackism
content that would be blog post and you
can translate any language with jity you
can write comparative headlines and
calls and you can also write social
media content that would be you can use
SEO research for that and you can write
short stories also see that he has given
you the blog post on the topic US
economy the navigating uh the title is
navigating the current state of the US
economy Trends and insights and you can
see that it has given you six points and
if you want more you can just ask him to
elaborate elaborate this and I want this
log
Post in 800
words so the thing you just have to do
is write the script write the prompt you
have to just prompt scripting and that
two in in the easy language that is in
English and you will get all your
answers from the chat
jpd so now it will write the blog post
that would be in 800
words
so that's good and moving on what we'll
do let's check out one of our Learners
what he has to say about our courses you
need to keep updating your skills on a
regular basis no matter what level you
at I recently completed the professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn in
partnership with P University the course
material was comprehensive and the
faculty was extremely experienced uh The
Faculty was able to adjust their
teaching style in order to cater to the
overall skill set of the class in the
rapidly evolving world of technology
it's important to keep upskilling for
every working professional stay relevant
continue learning now coming back so the
third passive income you could make
using CH JPS building a software imagine
this scenario you have an issue with
your online
business and you realize that many other
people are facing the same problem well
here's where chat jpd comes to the
rescue you can utilize chat jpd to
create software using the code provided
by the AI and then you can sell these
software tools to make money it's as
simple as that by leveraging chat JP's
powerful capabilities you can develop
innovative solutions to common problems
and turn them into valuable software
tools whether it's automating a task
streamlining a process or providing a
unique service the possibilities are
endless once you have created your
software tools you can Market them to a
target audience researching out to those
who can benefit from your solution and
guess what people are always always
looking for convenient and efficient
software tools to enhance their business
so there's a ready Market waiting for
you so selling software tools not only
allows you to earn a steady income but
also empowers others to overcome
challenges and improve their own
Ventures it's a a win-win situation so
if you're a problem solver and have a KN
of for coding why not use charity to
create software tools that can make a
real impact start by identifying common
pinpoints that also you can ask from
chat jpd you can just ask the chat jpd I
want to create a software to help others
during or in online processes in online
e-commerce so he'll give you suggestions
and then you can proceed with those
suggestions and create a software and
then you can sell it or you can use for
your own use so now and PR the power of
chat GPT tap into its coding expertise
and unlock the potential to create and
sell software tools so your journey to
financial success starts right here and
moving on we will move to the next
income source that we can gain from chat
gity so you can boost your affiliate
marketing with chat G's email expertise
so do you know that chj processes
exceptional writing skills it's true
this incredible chatboard can draft
convincing emails that motivate users to
take action whether it's clicking on
affiliate links making purchases or
subscribing to Services JJ has got you
cover its impressive ability to generate
engaging content you can Captivate your
audience and compel them to take the
desired actions so we'll get back to the
chat JP and ask him that I am an email
marketer and need to
sell my CRM
software so write an
email for me so I can
attract
customer and make them
bite
okay
now you could see that it is writing
email for you and you can launch your
email affiliate marketing campaign also
now that we understand the power of
chity let's discuss how you can
Kickstart your email affiliate marketing
campaign the first step is to choose an
affiliate program that aligns with your
Niche whether it's Amazon Spotify
Shopify convertkit or any other program
make sure it suits your target audience
next it's time to build an email list of
potenti customers who are genuinely
interested in your promoted products or
Services you can use lead magnets or
employ other effective methods to
encourage email signups you could see
that he has written the email that is I
hope this email finds you well as a
email
Market okay uh this is for me and you
could start from here at your company we
have developed a powerful C solution
tailer specifically for email marketers
like yourself our software combines
Advanced features user friendly okay he
is written for email marketers only he
has targeted audience that is email
marketer no issue you can ask him to
change that and like you can craft
compiling emails with ch jpd and this is
where CH JP truly shines with its
assistance you can create highly
engaging emails that not only inform
users about the benefits of the products
but also Inspire them to click on your
affiliate links and make purchases
imagine having a chatboard by your site
helping you write captivating emails
effortlessly but incorporating
persuasive language compiling
storytelling and personalized touch your
emails will stand out in crowded inboxes
and generate higher click through rates
so this is how chj can help you in email
marketing now the next method is
leverage CH jity for blogging success in
the realm of blogging CH J offers an
array of advantages that can elevate
your content creation Journey so the
first
is content generation so Unleash the
Power of this AI driven tool to spank
your creativity and overcome writers
block JJ assist bloggers by generating
ideas crafting outlines and even
providing complete DRS for blog post say
goodbye to our spend on Research with
Char you can access relevant information
statistics and facts and me seconds
elevate your bloging game and Unleash
Your Potential with this in invaluable
source and then you can edit and proof
it using chat jity if you have written
any content and get any content written
you could just write what we have
already written that was write a blog
post on US economy that we have seen in
freelancing uh side Hustle but here you
can write and not only write but also if
you have added some points with your
research you can prove read and edit by
using chat jpd that is for bloggers chat
jpd proves to be a valuable asset by
offering assistance in editing proof
reading and enhancing the overall
readability of your blog post it
provides suggestions and Corrections for
spelling grammar and comprehension
reducing errors and ensuring Clarity let
chat jpt Define your writing and ensure
your blog post shine with
professionalism the next what you can do
for your blogging journey is keyword
research and SE optimization so this is
a fundamental aspect of successful
blogging chy becomes your trusted
companion in optimizing your blog post
for search engin it suggests relevant
keywords to include guides you on
structuring your content for maximum
visibility Mee and offer steps to
enhance your online presence maximize
your blogs reach and attract more
organic traffic in chat jpts Su
expertise and then we have audience
engagement and I will also show you how
we can relate keywords so for SEO you
could just search that would be giveing
related SEO
keywords and SEO
keywords for and the topic could be
online
shopping and press enter so here are
some related SEO keywords for online
shopping you could see all these you
could mention these on your back links
if you have website or you could add
into your blog post hashtags which can
gain you rank when searched so moving
back the next was audience engagement so
engaging your audience is key to
building a thriving blow jgpt can assist
you in connecting with your readers on a
deeper level it provides conversation
status answer foron questions and
addresses concerns from your Audience by
leveraging chat's capabilities you can
force a meaningful interactions
cultivate a loyal following and Forge
lasting connections with your readers by
harnessing the power of chat jity
bloggers can consistently produce high
quality content Captivate their target
audience bolster their online presence
and generate passive income embrace the
potential of chy and embark on an
exciting blogging Journey it will leave
a lasting impact so moving on we will
now see another side hle that is unlock
the potential of CH jity for affiliate
marketing and you could do easily
affiliate marketing if you have this
blogging
thing so affiliate marketing opens up a
world of earning possibilities and CH
jity can be your trusted Ally on this
rewarding Journey users of CH can
leverage its capability is to generate
income through affiliate marketing this
powerful tool provides a seamless Avenue
for promoting Goods services and Brands
all while earning a commission based on
resulting sales embarking on an
affiliate marketing Venture requires
thoughtful planning as a blogger or
content creator you must carefully
select the medium through which you will
build your audience whether it's through
captivating articles engaging audio
content or compiling videos you have the
freedom to choose the format that aligns
with your strengths and resonates with
your target audience when you have
establish your audience building medium
chity steps into to support your
affiliate marketing efforts this AI
driven tool empowers you to craft
persuasive content that effectively
promotes the products or Services you
are affiliated with by collaborating
with Chad jity you can tap into its
exceptional writing skills and create
captivating promotional materials that
resonate with your audience as you
implement your affiliate marketing
strategy chj becomes an invaluable
resource it helps you draft engaging
articles record compelling audio content
or script captivating videos that
highlight the benefits and value of the
products or services that you are
promoting so remember affiliate
marketing is a process that requires
dedication and perseverance through
consistent effort and support of Charity
you can unlock the potential of earning
substantial income by promoting products
and services that resonate with your
audience and this was for the affiliate
marketing and the next big thing is
utilize jat jity for ebook writing and
self-publishing so are you a passionate
writer seeking fresh and in ative ideas
look no further chity revolutionizes
your writing experience in a recent
reports that reveal that AI ebooks have
experienced a remarkable search on
Amazon so you could just go on chat je
and ask him I want to write a self help
book add
to rism
free okay I think yeah now spelling is
correct blackism
free and it should
have
resonating chapters
resoning
chapters
so provide
me with the
list of
chapters as you can see that it will
Define you and you can also ask the
title for the book and it will give you
the perfect title and you can see the
chapter that is introducing setting the
stage for personal growth discovering
your authentic self cultivating a
positive mindset and after that you can
ask J to elaborate these topics that
would be in some words in some pages and
you can use the same content to write a
book and you can also ask the title from
the JJ so with JJ as your creative
companion the possibilities are
boundless you don't need to possess the
skills of literary genius to make an
impact in the ebook Market Kindle Direct
publishing offers seamless platform to
Showcase your book and make it easily
accessible to enthusiastic readers by
aaging chity to assistant writing your
ebook you will save precious time and
energy allowing you to concentrate on
marketing and promoting your work
effectively so this is how you can write
ebooks and generate income using charity
moving on we have next passive income
that is utilize chat jpt to enhance your
YouTube channel so chat jpt is an
invaluable tool that can assist you in
generating captivating video ideas you
can ask him the video ideas also and
this is a creative block CH can even go
the extra mile by creating a script for
your YouTube videos so let's step into
the creative press and we'll ask J jpt I
want to create a YouTube
video on
topic uh
GDB that is close domestic product
and I need your
help
writing the script for
that so you could see that J JP has
started its work so it's showing welcome
back to our channel in today's video
we'll be diving into the fascinating
world of GB GDP what exactly is GDP and
why is it such an important measure of a
country's economy so you can see that it
has created the script for your YouTube
video and it is also telling you the
scenes so this is how you could leverage
ch's capabilities and that can give your
YouTube channel a significant boost
helping you create engaging content and
capture the attention of your audience
so start exploring the possibilities
with ch today and witness your channel
five so moving on the next we have is
writing lyrics for music so when it
comes to music the words we use in songs
are super important they have the power
to make us feel all kinds of emotions
and connect with people and now there's
a cool tool called chj that can help you
write awesome song lyrics with chj you
can take your ideas and turn them into
beautiful words that touch people's
heart it's like having a virtual writing
buddy that help you come up with catchy
lines and cool Rhymes you can play
around with different ways to express
yourself and make your lyric stand out
so you can chat GPD to WR lyrics for you
have a look at wide range of eiml
courses by simply learn in collaboration
with top universities across the globe
find the cost Link in the description
box the intention behind your questions
are the countless number of development
and the emerging ones like Megatron
Albert Electra T5 and many more these
three models are currently ruling the
space of AI language models Bing b and
chat gbd and today we will understand
the differences similarities and the
abilities that make them stand out and
try to decide which one is the best hey
everyone welcome to Simply LA's YouTube
channel and today we bring you the Bing
versus the Google bar the chat GPD but
before we begin if these are the type of
videos you would like to watch hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
if you are an aspiring artificial
intelligence engineer looking for an
online training and certification from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts so
that you have the most robust Foundation
skills knowledge and what it takes to
become the best then search no more
simply learns postgraduation program in
artificial intelligence from Pur
University in collaboration with IBM
should be your right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below also want to get access to
more informative content like this one
get subscribed to us and hit hit the
Bell so that you are the first to get to
know when we host with that in mind
let's start with the elephant in the
room that is the chat
gbd chat gbd was released on the 30th of
November 2022 it uses the GPT LM to
elaborate llm is an approvation for
large language model and chat GPT is
globally available to its users using
the generative pre-trained Transformer
also called as chat GPT llm with 1
trillion parameters as its variables
learned during the model training now
the Bing Microsoft was one of the
largest investors in open AI Bing is an
AI language model created in
collaboration with open Ai and publicly
released on the 4th of May 2023 Bing
uses the same data set that chat GPT
uses Bing has an H over chat GPT as
Microsoft integrates its Prometheus with
about
135 billion parameters now next up we
have Bard B is Google's answer to chat
gbt with limited capabilities and
lukewarm responses it was released on
21st of March 2023 B initially started
off with Lambda llm with a caliber of
137 billion parameters Google's CEO ASAS
Bard will switch to pathway model named
as pal 2 llm with about 400 billion plus
parameters to take on chat gbd head-
onhe head in generating responses and
the application codes and programs with
the details discussed let's move ahead
to some of the important parameters to
be considered to discuss the differences
firstly user interface and experience
chat gbd has a simple and subtle
interface making it easy to understand
and get along with the usage so chat
gpt's user interface looks something
like this chat GPT has a simple Dark
theme interface focusing on providing
users with high quality language
processing capabilities rather than
immersive visuals you can ask questions
get answers and even you can ask to
enhance or optimize the answer according
to your needs again user needs to
manually request chat GPD the other hand
being a small incline towards giving a
blissful visual experience to their
users by choosing brilliant background
images color interfaces and emojis so a
typical Bing user interface looks
something like this in addition to that
it is backed up by chat gpt's data set
and prome llm to help users with the
best and- class answers to their
questions it even delivers three
different answers at the same time
creative balanced and precise are the
three variants and you can choose the
best ones which suits your requests now
lastly b b is a little different from
from others unlike others B just dumps
the answers at once enthusiasts call it
fast but it misses the human touch of
giving the answers in a word by word
typing manner yet similar to Bing it
manages to give you different versions
of the answers besides that B has a
decent interface and its logo shines
with multiple colors giving you the
feeling of B processing the data to give
you a better result now let's try to ask
a few most frequ ly asked questions to
part chat gbd and ping let's ask with a
simple one are you friends
with chat
GPT and Bing you can see The Shining
logo of Bot and you have just seen the
way how Google bot answers you it just
dumps the answer now if you go or if you
ask the same question to the other ones
like Char gbd and Bing let's see how
they respond and you can see you have
other drafts as well right so you can
see draft one draft two and draft three
so you can choose any ones which you
feel are more optimized and you know
deliverable according to your requests
right now let's go back to Ping right
now let's ask the same
question are you friends
with chat GPT
and
but see the word by word typing approach
of Bing and chity give you a little more
immersive feeling that somebody is
really talking to you right and you also
have the freedom of choosing the answer
wisely right so it gives you three
different options which are creative
balanced and precise right and on just
one single scroll you have the Bing
search open here right this is one other
good way of using Bing in the in case if
you have any questions that are
unanswered or which did not satisfy you
you can also go back to Bing and you can
manually search for the data and get the
information right now let's get back to
chat
GPD and here let's ask the same question
are you friends
with Bing and
B
see so that's how individual a models
respond to each other and now let's get
back to the next point of discussion
which is what is the data or history
about the questions you asked or the
prompts you have opened that each one of
these stores
so this is about the conversation
history or the prompt that you have with
individual one of these AI
models first comes the chat gbd chat gbd
claims they do not store any data about
its interaction with its users but in
chat GPD you can access the promps and
questions you asked you can also export
your transcripts in chat GPD on the
other hand we have bing bing says they
do not have any history or promps of
your previous conversations as well and
lastly b b is a little mix and match of
both so what bar does is it Stores Only
the prompts whereas in chat GPD when you
ask a question it will store the
question and the answer it gave you but
but it'll only store The Prompt that is
the question you asked and not the
answer it gave to you so with that the
next point of discussion would be the
mobile version of each one of the these
as of now Chad GPT hasn't released any
of the official mobile application
version yet and on the other hand on
Bing it has just one click of a button
and you can click it and Bing Launches
on your mobile phone and Bing has a
mobile variant with similar and much
better Aesthetics that can get started
on a touch of an app launcher and lastly
we have B Bard has a similar approach to
its mobile variant Google has enabled B
usage in Google mobile application as as
well and now comes the number of
questions asked disclaimer if you want
to work on a project presentation or
thesis choose your AI model wisely
because if you are close to wrapping up
your project and the AI model says sorry
pal you're out of your wishes Yes you
heard me right a few of these language
models have a limitation on the number
of questions asked on one single topic
or one single keyword or one single
concept let's look into details before
we proceed to the next part of this
video let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their Curious hey I'm
sharar Jal I live in Ontario Canada I
have been in it sector for the past 20
years I recently took the professional
certificate program in artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
course has changed the way I look at
things and help me back some amazing
freelance projects I started my career
in 1999 and over the years I have worked
with many companies my last tener was
with IBM Canada my aim was to restart my
career and learn something that would
help accelerate my
career I thought artificial intelligence
can make me Future Ready the course in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning has provided by simply learn in
association with Purdue University which
is why I chose the course I did not have
high expectations from online course but
my experience was simply awesome the
quality of interaction within the course
was simply amazing the course faculty
was also very experienced and
knowledgeable after the course my
knowledge has grown manifold I have
immensely benefited from Python and
coding skills I am able to get some new
freelance projects also I am planning to
start an AI based startup with my friend
where I feel that the learning from the
course to be very helpful I am really
delighted and happy in my free time I
try to create meaningful content on
YouTube and I talk about new
technologies and what kind of courses
professionals should be taking along
with with many other topics I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the
B first comes chat GPD chat GPD takes 25
questions on a single keyword or a
single subject or a single topic of
discussion post that it refrains from
answering your questions same with Bing
it takes no more than 20 questions on
single keyword or a single topic or a
single concept but now comes
Brad Brad is a little different Brad
kind of said Stakes a little too high it
almost has no limits to your questions
you can ask any number of questions to B
and that can be a real deal breaker
lastly we will differentiate these AI
models based on their product activity
yes exactly we do know all these three
models are smart but how smart exactly
how humanly are they how close are they
in convincing you with an optimistic
answer what's their potential to judge a
hypothetical question and give you a
balanced answer sounds interesting right
let's get started first let's start with
chat GPD so let's say I want to learn Ai
and machine learning so obviously this
should be able to teach me that
let's ask
it can you teach
me
artificial
intelligence machine
learning
brilliant it gave me a brief about
artificial intelligence machine learning
types of machine learning and deep
learning in one go and it also convinced
you here right yes as nii model I can
certainly help you with that right so
it's a good answer now let's try to ask
a little different one or
can it plan a Nary or can it buy me a
product online or can it do some uh
other things like booking me in Uber
right so let's try can
you
purchase an
online training
program for AI and ml
brilliant Chad GPA knows its limits
right as an AI model I cannot directly
purchase online right it's giving you
the brutal truth here that's good and
apart from that it also gave you a
stepbystep procedure to buying your
course do your research check the
curriculum check the instructor what's
the format what's the cost right a few
parameters which you might want to
consider before buying a course right so
now let's try to question the same
queries to Bing so since Bing and chat
gbt share the same training data set I
could expect a similar answer but let's
see it is taking a while I guess
Prometheus is a little slower compared
to GPD okay there might be a connection
issue let's ask the question once
again wow it's way too better than chat
GPD so it is even asking you details on
if you if you are looking for a specific
topic or a gender overview let's say I
would need a general
overview I could straight away say Bing
is a little more smarter and productive
compared to chat jpd but still we have
one more Contender to compare with B
right so there might be again the
internet
connection now let's say we refresh Bing
once again and straight away ask the the
second question what we had right that
is can you buy me a
course online
course for
learning
artificial think did give me a good
answer for the previous question
question let's see what kind of an
answer it gives me now I'm sorry but I'm
not capable of making online purchases
however I can find you some online
courses for learning AI would you like
me to search for some options brilliant
so this is a little more optimized
answer compared to chat gbd 1's and it
is also honest it does know its limits
fine it can help you search for some
online courses but again uh CH GPD G
give us some parameters to consider
right so I would give or I would choose
to tie them up here they are on the tie
now our last Contender that is B let's
try to ask the same questions to B so
here is B now let's try to ask questions
to B let's say can you teach
me machine
learning you can see the B logo shining
there
now it should be dumping the answer
anytime soon yeah of course we do miss
that humanly Touch of giving the answer
in a word by word typing
way let's refresh and ask the question
again can you teach
me machine
learning this is a little too
straightforward I'm a language model and
don't have the capacity to help you out
so okay let's not give up here let's try
to ask the second question can you
purchase an
online training
program to
me to
learn machine
learning
yes I can help you purchase an online
program for machine learning here are a
few things that you need to
consider
good it's not being brutally honest here
it is saying it can help you out so
again what I intended to expect here was
you cannot just directly buy an online
program right you need some details
credentials and everything to purchase
so again it is is sugar coating the
answer and it is definitely giving you
suggestions similar to chat GPD but a
little different which focuses on your
learning style level of experience your
budget good nice way to answer some
questions like this one so all these
three ones are brilliant and good in
their own way so it might be a little
difficult to declare who's the winner as
of now since the B AI model is going to
switch to Palm 2 and we are expecting
some updates to each one of these with
that we can consider currently they are
standing next to each other with similar
capabilities and better enhancement in
different fields so with that having
said we can conclude this session on
chat GPD versus Bing versus B and if you
would like me to answer the conclusion I
would say well it seems like we all have
our strengths and weaknesses at the end
of the day it comes to what users value
the most do they want a visually
appealing interface strong privacy
protections or the ability to converse
with an AI language model it's up to
them to decide so here we wrap up full
course on chat gbd if you have any
questions feel free to post them in the
comment section share the video with
your friends and do not forget to like
share and subscribe to Simply learn to
never miss any updates from us thanks
for watching staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry EXP
choose any of our programs and set
yourself on the path to Career Success
click the link in the description to
know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here